before we jump in this juicy ass podcast
with my boy maz
and the boys san marcos texas this
friday
this saturday january 29th january 30th
i'm in san marcos texas all the shows
are damn near sold out few tickets are
left pick them up
these will sell out don't try give them
the night of the
freaking shows they're gonna sell out so
get your tickets as you're listing this
go to fatkz.com or tfatk.com
wherever you want to check me out at
f-a-t-k-z.com san marcos texas this
friday
and saturday we will see you guys we're
stoked and then next on the books
february 26th through the 27th i'm in
tampa florida
let's do it you tom brady [ __ ]
tampa
florida february 26th through the 27th
come get your tickets
come get some this episode is brought to
you by the best supplements on planet
earth i don't know about everybody else
it's [ __ ] if it ain't on it it ain't
[ __ ] go to
promo code fighter or on it dot com
slash fighter
all right and get 10 off alpha brain new
mood total gut health
earth grow nutrients protein powder
fitness gear i got you covered man
say less on it kettlebells steel club
maces
you want to work out from home got you
covered man from your phone you can
stream
fitness on at 6 barbell body weight
durability
kettlebell steel club steel mace on at 6
streaming fitness
on-demand workouts on it in 30. all
right morning mobility
move and groove we got you covered man
no reason to stay on healthy thick be a
cool thick
let on it help you go to onit.com
fighter
10 off the entire goddamn site you're
welcome
[Music]
because he asked me about my ego do you
get uh pedicures i said not that i just
chew on my fingers a lot
always have cat you had you chewed on
your fingers because anxiety yeah
as a kid i always uh bit off my
fingernails because i was always anxious
and then if i'll do it my teeth no
i didn't want to ruin them that's what
it was like they looked pretty and i
didn't want to touch it
my my uh cousin beck shout out to bec
she used to put
um oh that's like nail polish on here
she's like you're not gonna like the
taste of it i love the taste of it
oh like this is gonna stop like yeah no
doubt oh hell yeah ugh
flavor flavor now we got flavor they
make one specifically with a bad flavor
not just like a right
that's the one i have thick young
brendan yeah
i mean you can tell i've had a rough
week you know my fingers even more
you asked if there if if i get pedicures
though yeah i thought i thought you did
but
you know you would start to [ __ ] yeah it
started to
my bottom two fronts started to cave in
because my
teeth were still shifting at that that's
how mine was it now looks kind of like
my teeth to this day are like this
because my dad went nah you good
we already got your brother braces yeah
braces are expensive they're expensive
especially back then my brother had the
full
metal gear solid yeah did he have the
headpiece too where did you have the
headpiece
i should probably do something now but
bruh they had draymond green sponsoring
invisalign i said that's not the
range you the person you want to get to
sponsor yeah what's this like
calendar invisalign for a hot second
just didn't do anything
and then he came in about 50 years old
with invisalign with a list
when ain't doing this right everybody if
you're gonna do this show you gotta take
him out man
yeah he had he'd come in with invisalign
but then sipping coffee and [ __ ] like
yeah
it's like coffee gets stuck yeah but
invisalign takes way longer than braces
yeah because it's metal it grains i have
braces so i was like for three years
yeah yeah you got straight ass teeth i
don't think what about me
you know what have you seen the the girl
for i think smile
girl for a smile smile yeah i've seen
the commercial
the black girl and she's like i used to
have a big gap she's in high school
she's like kids just give me [ __ ]
she just say [ __ ] but she's like kids
just give me a bunch of [ __ ] then i got
smile thanks smile and it's
your teeth were identical to yours and
then now it cleared it up
oh they they they they they close this
yeah
that's character that's gotta be like
you [ __ ]
yeah you jade bryce uh michael strahan
huh it's a bracelet actually i think
jamie foxx fixed his
yeah people out there be fixing the gap
you never
i'm about to do a photo shoot for show
time on monday i'm like damn i was like
hello
really oh we got paulie today today like
yeah sorry man cameron guy's just here
today like
oh okay can you can you
edit my hair can you
you photoshop back in longer here
i look good though as long as you've had
it like did you have it long when you
were a kid
no not when i was when i had an afro as
a kid but then
both my kids that have afros too but
then
just
in college uh me and my roommates did
our i think yeah our senior year did a
thing where
who had the like uh who could grow their
hair the longest
yeah and i thought mine was me all like
long and [ __ ] like yeah
you could be like no my [ __ ] was like
this like like pam grier
james was straight and black like down
to here really are you serious
well you had a fro like pam yeah it was
like a jew froze like really
juicy and it was like i look real i look
like
like the og shia labeouf from evan
stephens yes
okay like lionel richie like you old
school like 70s line of riches
okay it had some soul in it she was kind
of yeah yeah you had some soul
yeah this [ __ ] was popping you were like
oh it was running my football helmet
come out the back
covered up yeah [ __ ] was dope that
little curl come on
it was dope looking like ice cube and
easy in the 80s yeah see you
but if when you like now when you have
money you can figure it out
and like make it look good in college
you're broke
i should just grow out like this dude
i've come to realize
i don't mind dropping money on a haircut
get what you pay for i
i do not mind your haircut yeah exactly
who'd you go to uh dude uh
a fan messaged me this spot it's called
gray matter upon like la brea but
not not too far from my house a bunch of
fans said
uh i don't mean interruptions set uh
recommendations
some dude sent a guy he's in venice he's
like dude he cuts
everybody and gave us a list of the
celebrities
this is the guy and i tell brennan you
know what i don't care i'll drop the
[ __ ] out
of the shop the [ __ ] money get what's
your paper
get what you get
yeah cause xbox they gotta get i grow my
hair exactly the same
like when i shot the uh commercial that
was like put these waves continuity yeah
they said get rid of the waves i forget
what your hair was like before the waves
yeah
it was kind of like that but like oh for
my hair growing out i'm getting a break
yeah dawg see hell yeah thanks for this
yeah that shit's gonna be dope what
i like your hair you right now you look
like carl winslow who carl whizzle he
had no hair
i'm a family man yeah you know i know
what's up
eddie winslow oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's
hey he killing on this show um
uh on a sneaky pete killing it
was stinky pete's been out for a hot
second right that's the english show yes
show oh yeah amazon prime yeah he's on
it like the black guy big he swole yeah
he's on there
yeah he's a big [ __ ] you know
what show i've been watching what's that
cobra kai oh people love it oh i heard
it's so good
i love it what's that a little cheesy
cobra cry it's so it's basically
off karate basically karate based on
karate kids but they're all older right
but they're all older and more so
they're like running dojos i'm awesome
bro you didn't even give it a chance no
i did it you know i got offered to do a
small
role in that buzz like [ __ ] don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
fighting
listen listen what's up netflix i love
the show because i love karate start on
facebook right yeah started on no start
on youtube
started on youtube red or whatever the
netflix picture yeah that's right uh
will smith uh produces it or whatever
but um i mean i love karate kid
right and so it brings back that like
nostalgia
feeling to like the karate but but
listen okay
i'm telling you ufc is a [ __ ] big
thing now and it's a real thing
so if it like it it doesn't make sense
but like if you like if you watch it
you're kind of you're going to be like
what the [ __ ] is this cause the fighting
is not people yeah
you know karate [ __ ] yeah so like the
fighting yeah
it doesn't what obviously if he watches
it yeah he's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
this this is not real
oh netflix yeah just got on netflix two
two yeah just uh no it's a three season
yeah people dude yeah they got a fourth
season people love it bro it's it's
this avoid topics cheesy a little cheesy
no cheesy but
it's like it's just dope and the writing
is really good i've heard
it's great but it's i'm not a cornball i
l i love it because i i love that
you grew up on karate i grew up on
you break my record now i break you yeah
wait don't get back
what does he say jay would come in and
start cool
our dad would just put that on but yeah
i'm gonna take off dude blood sport is
gangster great movie great [ __ ] movie
like it's
the only thing is at the end you know
it's like frank dudes or he's like hey
well thank you guys so long oh yeah
oh no he's all yeah you know they put up
the quote
like the the stats of frank dukes did
they lie
you've never seen more like [ __ ]
that's what there's no stats
oh my god a frank dukes yeah it was like
55-0 heavyweight champion
67 knockouts in a row yeah prove it
prove it that's what i'm saying bro
joe rogan throw a [ __ ] spinning kick
kind of bag and beat that right now
yeah uh no you talking about the real
guy or the the real guy
the real guy frank dude real guy
what's that part at the end when he
gives this homie is uh
a he's all anytime anywhere
if you need me just say the word they've
known each other for
two weeks three weeks he goes i love you
bro i think that's good i've known each
other for two weeks
i've never seen more movie more in my
entire life
so 329 wins zero losses
[ __ ] i call complete [ __ ] so you
really think it's [ __ ] 100 percent
why the [ __ ] they have this up here then
but wait because
you can never find out because it said
one loss and then it says zero losses so
what what
what are we talking about right now well
yeah 321 wins
but here goes he told access tv he had
retired with a fight record of
329 and zero oh gotcha okay okay really
i called [ __ ] really i love
bloodsport and frank oh yes
come on oh [ __ ] how about that reporter
that gets [ __ ] down
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you're repeating the line i'm trying
to get to know him the whole time bro
dang that dang what's the top five that
so does he put blood sport in the top
five karate movie
uh yeah i would yeah 100 what's the
number one for you
flush with me for sure number one yeah
yeah i would have to go with blood
support as well
into the dragon i love uh into the
dragons really good dragons up there
um yeah a lot of bruises lead [ __ ] but
like blissful is just some i don't know
there's bloodsport lionheart
kickboxer all john claude van damme
movies
there's enter the dragon you know i like
some of uh
michael jai white's uh film oh hell yeah
i mean they're kind of they're gonna
cheesy but i love that stuff i keep
gotta like the cheesy stuff oh i love
that she's like any
rubble on the brock's oh never back down
back down todd duffy was in it
i think part two was todd he never back
down he was a fighter but he was a
fighter yeah
stud yeah never back down i like that
movie
um that's a hard pass
i can't emphasize enough how hard i
passed
he said that's all this [ __ ]
i i just don't like those movies i like
bach
that's a good one that's a good one he'd
be [ __ ] yeah
i don't like the new fight stuff i like
the old stuff old stuff
yeah rubble in the bronx jackie chan
i love that one would you consider that
a fight movie though yeah rumble in the
bronx
no yeah that's jackie chan being the
[ __ ] out of just like
new york 80 dudes yeah
about warriors about mickey ward face
off make you you're way off it's about
mickey warren no i've never seen that oh
and then uh who's the fighter and then
his brother uh played by the guy who's
batman
ben affleck no it's all christian bale
christian battle christian
is unreal in that movie well not just to
the great that's right
that's what i'm looking for it is oh
that's what you were like romeo must die
remember on the other side
yeah that one too come on talk about the
fighter [ __ ]
movie no no no i didn't say dude what
about
though but it's a fighting movie it's
legit right full of the fighter
christian bale the fighter yeah with
mark wahlberg that's a box
yeah yeah i mean boxing's fine didn't
they have like
this movie's unreal dude oh really yeah
you don't have to like
fighting and you'd [ __ ] love this man
and it's based off mickey roar
yeah uh brother he's he's so good in it
dude
he's so good in it mark wahlberg oh my
god
unreal amy i'm [ __ ] with mark wahlberg
dude
christian bell is a hell of a actor by
the way some would say the best
yeah the mom's so good in that movie no
and that's
okay did they have anterior gotti
fighting there
yes okay it's such a good movie man
i'm gonna check that out damn i was
talking what's that ufc movie that came
out that a lot of people were it was in
the ring
don't [ __ ] with any of those ufc movies
which movie
do you see the one that you're
pronouncing the one they're promoting
what you didn't see that and it's like
this actor and he had the deep
he had a button up but he unbuttoned it
he's like hey guys once you check out my
new movie
dropping this saturday it was like oh
hell no
you've never seen it oh it looks so bad
so bad i'll still watch it is it during
257 yeah
is it old fighter releasing it no
i don't know what the fight movie is it
looks [ __ ]
awful i love it i love a good fight
movie though
any fight movie really oh yeah yeah
honestly the hard part it's the fighting
that get like
obviously watching the movie for the
fighting have you ever seen into the
furnace
again christian bale and uh casey
affleck's
his he comes back from war and they're
in pittsburgh
and his you know his brother like has
ptsd he needs money
so he starts [ __ ] uh the underground
knuckle underground you know the
ringleader of the bare knuckle boxing
is uh is uh what do you do woody harris
woody harrelson
dude that movie's on [ __ ] who else
you got
you know who wrote it sheridan you know
what else sam sharon writes
yellowstone i thought his name is taylor
sheridan no
sam shared it sam sherry you got four's
whitaker here
yeah forced wickets for yes i said his
girl
casey affleck william defoe i know what
i'm gonna do in texas
who i can't believe you guys never seen
that one no i didn't bro i need to write
this down
the furnace and the fighter into the
furnace answer the fighter sam shepard
sam oh no out of the furnace out of the
furnace
fantastic movie out of the first
cylinder in the fighter
writing these down you're not having a
movie about uh kimbo slice
uh winston duke yeah i know yeah that
should be really good well is that
something you're
watching because you must slice yeah
okay if it's well
yeah that's my guy if it's well done if
it's like
cheesy like like that pro that whatever
that fight movie is they
they promoted on you that looked [ __ ]
awful
this 47 year old actor on trt
did a few jiu jitsu classes like you
know it's a good idea a fight movie
yeah they have all these cameos from
real ufc fighters
it's such a hard [ __ ] pass for me
harvest
is it is it the same energy as the tyson
one the tyson movie
yes but i'd say well that tights one
looked [ __ ] awful
yeah they had the mountain on there um
not seeing it
yeah i want to say yeah the fans let us
know i want to see that movie but
yeah i think the winston duke because
he's a great actor i love them in uh
black panther
panther i never saw black panther never
uh no desire
no you're not a superhero movie guy are
you i like batman i like joker
you know i like these songs you're not
like i like
yeah and then obviously the black
panther thing like everyone was
[ __ ] sucking the black panther off
him
here it is legendary oh no
not ah [ __ ] i'll look for it oh
uh nope i don't know what it's called
it's so [ __ ] ridiculous looking
dude speaking of fighting how about uh
jake paul been asking official
that's official that's official we
picked with a boycott
he's not a striker like that though he's
not a striker but
he is a his resume is ridiculous
it's it is the perfect fight for jake
paul as far as like trying to step
up to the next level because ben askren
you know you're talking about uh
all-american i think national champion
missouri ncaa wrestling
yeah he was on the olympia he was an
olympian on the wrestling so
[ __ ] can wrestle wrestle as far
as mma credentials dude you're talking
about a guy who is a
one championship world champion he's a
bellator champion
he went he fought robbie lawler but uh
lima like he's
he's been in there with [ __ ] killers
i hear you
didn't get knocked out i hear you
brendan but that was all those accolades
wrestling gravel
this is this is fighting he got he got a
box yeah i thought his hands
yeah and i think that his i i know i did
a little youtube do my research because
i wanted to see who he was fighting
his stand-up is not like his status bad
so jake paul i mean it's eight rounds
too and you know we both know three
minutes and you know boxing's very
different
cardio and all that so i think that jake
paul might stop
body shots uh i don't he's not gonna
stop
the body if he stops him he's gonna
knock him out early
what i want to see is for the evolution
of jake paul
is if this gets past three rounds i know
it'll get past three rounds
you think well if he goes past three
rounds
it's definitely gonna sway more towards
ben aspen that fight goes on
you know how it is in boxing jake just
doesn't have the experience
yeah yeah you don't have the experience
or the fundamentals or
the technique it once once that initial
shot if it doesn't put
ben down yeah that's when it when it
gets interesting like if he goes in and
starts
bend in the first round we're not going
to learn too much about jake
yeah because he's be you know he's
knocked out two guys two and oh yeah
one like him knocked on listen nate
robinson great basketball player bless
his heart
ken dunk he ain't [ __ ] in boxing he's
never fought
you're talking about a guy in ben who's
you know he's an actual fighter dude
he's a hall of famer
yeah he's the greatest to ever do it but
he's crossing over a sport though but
you're talking about a mentality
olympian mentality i got you coming over
to
that box and this is this is where the
paul brothers have to be
you know i talked about this before and
below the belt like they have to be a
little
careful stepping into the real world of
fighting and they're in the lane now
because
you beat ben where you go from there
where you go for where you have to be
you're talking about a guy who's a
two-time
world champion in two organizations
where you go from there
you can't you can't go back fighting
select no celebrity's gonna fight you
now
lamar odom's still looking forward to he
ain't [ __ ] okay he's gonna fight lamar
he's not big enough name and he can't
fight so for jake it's like all right
now you let's say he does starch bend
the first round where'd he go
what do you do where do you go from
there you build up confidence
yeah but you can't there's no going back
so you just be the two
organization world champion uh olympian
a national cha
a monster in the mma space where do you
go from there
you know what i'm saying it's like
there's no no celebrities like all right
i'll fight him
but i i think you're better than ben
hasken no yeah well can we he's going to
he's going to stay in the lane of like
fighting fighters yeah
because this is the first real fighter
yeah like and like ben's not scared in
any fashion
yeah i think you got to realize he's
going from nate robinson
but you got him guys never fought in any
capacity
any level yeah who demons spar leaning
up to the fight knocked him out
yeah god bless them good for you and to
ben asking who
listen he's been in the robbie lawler
he's been there with the
mods of it all he's been there's some
monsters and you know obviously mazda
knocked him out but
like douglas lima's a savage uh
i get no matter what organization ian is
a savage
he didn't get knocked out by him that's
true molly wapped him for five rounds
well you can't underestimate jake paul
because let me just tell you i
i think they really love boxing they're
already rich most boxers they fight to
get a better
you know better livelihood yeah so
but jake paul already has money he
already has fame he has the
the following he wants to fight he loves
boxing you know so the fact that
he's like okay cool i want to fight he's
going for it so yeah so you said like
yeah where he goes from here he wants to
fight i think he wants to be champion
it's a weird it's a weird you know how
to do it at his age and
let's say he does 24 right yeah he beats
ben
you're talking about a guy with for at
that point in three fights
yeah three fights yeah so if enoch's
been out in
in in the first round you're talking
about it with three fights
three rounds i think you're gonna fight
you're gonna fight connor next
no no what do you what do you do you
know fight manny pacquiao what are you
gonna do
it's possibilities but i think he really
loves boxing he's gonna continue to i
don't know it's a unique route
because i think i think it's a perfect
match-up for him like
because you know that mma i don't know
how you guys aren't balls deep in mma
but ben asking it's a lot of [ __ ] he
talks a lot of [ __ ] that's what
ben's a troll oh god i got it but again
it gets deluded because yeah ben talks a
lot of [ __ ] and he's a troll but ben
is as far as in our world mma yeah a
bad [ __ ] yeah so if jake knocks
him out
he's you know the mma community's now i
think is behind ben
because nobody wants cj quinn yeah maybe
his youtube fans do but outside that
boxing doesn't want to see him win
boxer's like dude get the [ __ ] out of
here
he hasn't put in the work like we have
he's getting these big paydays
like you know yeah we're not so the boss
he's going to bring the boxing
audience because they want to see him
get knocked out the mma committee
is repping ben every all of us are
repping ben shut up
i love the paul brothers obviously i'm
repping ben he you know i'm an alumni
so shut up bill's mafia
four days four days not bad football the
day's changing it's every day yeah it
might have been two days i forget
it was two days i was on the team for
two days
yeah so everyone's with ben every like
that mma
is gonna side with ben and he's kind of
been like that you know he's been the
troll so people
you know the the the meme of ben getting
knocked out by jorge mazda is like
it's like the biggest bro that was the
fastest knockout then why i need but
it's a shame because that
like that perspective on ben
doesn't do him justice of the skills
that he has take out that mazda thing
even with the muzzle knockout in
whatever seven seconds four seconds it's
a great
you're still talking about a hall of
famer yeah
not in the ufc but in mixed martial arts
he's a straight-up bonafide
gold jacket hall of famer so the mma
community is going to back ben asking
for really the first time
yeah and then the boxing community is
going to back ben askren
really for the first time yeah the pop
culture is probably going to back
jake makes a better fight yeah
but it's the perfect matchup i like it
honestly who did jake fight before
nate he no he's only one another so
judge oh that was
oh that was his first just so you know
so like you look at uh bet asking so
that
that course korskov the who he tko'd
monster monster where we look here andre
korskov
[ __ ] monster t.k odom that's for the
bellator world championship douglas lima
one of the best strikers ever yeah ever
decision
ever decision didn't get knocked out jay
hiron split decision
monster dude monster okay
uh uh shinier aoki
hall of famer yeah okay robbie lawler
hall of famer
t.k.o i see punches i see punches so
okay but that's on the ground we just
mounting them right
mm-hmm okay all right let's go to jake
paul resume real quick i want to just
well you know there's two fights the
nate robinson you know and then the
other is a youtuber
oh he fought a youtube youtuber there's
only two rounds on jake paul
there's just unknown and i'm not saying
that ben's gonna win
what i'm saying is it's a different
fight than
ensign gibb yes i get one nate robinson
it's just a dif it's just a different so
he only he's only been in a round for
three
three rounds in uh boxing a professional
okay so
if that if though that's his fighting
world right there
yeah why does he want to go because he
loves
with all those boxing i just told you
about ben askren it's still the perfect
fight for
for jake paul because the like my dad's
gonna be like
hey he's fighting a ufc guy like yeah
he's like oh wow he's really doing it
it's like
yes but you're talking about ben ashton
even though the level that he's at has
some of the worst striking of all time
in professional fighting yeah his
striking's awful yeah
but he didn't have to focus on striking
he was like all right
i'm so good at grappling that's all i'm
gonna do
so now you're talking about so it's it's
not just
a one percenter it's it's just different
because
he again he's stepping over into the
world of real fighters yeah and ben's
not scared of him and ben has come up
with game plans before
to beat elite strikers and has won those
fights
so my whole thing on this is if j
to me what makes this fight curious and
i will 100 buy it
is if it goes past two rounds and jake
doesn't
knock him out how does jake respond it's
gonna be tough to knock up endless first
got him
i'm telling he's been there with some of
the very best to ever do it with france
gloves on
and they didn't stand a chance so you so
so who you have winning this fight
sounds like you have been
oh no no it's not that i have been or
that i have jake
i'm i want to see it go past two rounds
and see how jake responds
if jake does well and uses his jab and
uses footwork
hurts him and doesn't get overzealous
and make mistakes
you know it looks good it's like all
right well [ __ ] this dude has a career
all right because again ben's the real
and ben had hip surgery like ben's whole
career especially in the future his ufc
career was a little too late
like he did all his work outside the ufc
and then ufc signed him
but he had major hip issues he had hip
surgery so now his hips better
so you're talking about major hip issues
he was always like
hindered in the ufc people don't realize
that and like me and rogan
advocate for that guy to come to ufc for
years before they signed them
because he was undefeated he was so good
he didn't have a lobster he came to the
ufc
unreal dude then you're talking about an
olympian mentality
fighting a youtuber that's kurt angle
that's what's crazy yeah
kurt angle yeah he's an olympian right
yeah he's the olympian then he went
straight wwe
uh also while we being on the subject of
fighting we'd get off how about ryan
garcia dad said
uh manny pacquiao fight is close to
being made the deal is done
today's episode with mars my brother
from another iranian mother is brought
to you by the kratom experts at
superspeciosa
that's right you've heard me talk about
kratom you've heard chin talk about
kratom
chin takes it with water i take it uh
just in pill form however you want to
get it delivered get it done with super
speciosa
you got to start thinking like elon musk
and get your kratom on if you've never
heard of kratom it's a herbal supplement
kind of like cbd
but instead of coming from a cannabis
plant it's from something close to a
coffee tree
people use kratom every day i use it
every morning
every afternoon every night when i do
stand-up podcasting i won't do anything
without it i swear by it
but you can't just get it from anybody
man you gotta be able to trust them
it's the wild west of the kratom game
that's why
they're super speciosa that's right they
keep
kratom the way nature intended it's pure
you can trust them trust me here i rock
with their stuff
if you're going to try kratom it has to
be from superspeciosa
that's right they're offering you guys
20 off go to getsuperleaf.com
that's get super l e a f
dot com enter the promo code fighter for
20 off that's getsuperleaf.com
promo code fighter listen there's nobody
on the planet like you so why would you
buy a generic mattress built for
everybody else you're wondering why
you're not getting a good night's sleep
let helix sleep help you out all you
gotta do is take a quick quiz for them
it takes two minutes to complete then it
matches your thick ass
body type or skinny body type if you're
a stick boy
with the exact mattress built for your
body your side sleeper hot sleeper plush
firm with helix there's no more
confusion no more compromising on an
average mattress helix sleep was awarded
the number one best overall
mattress in 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine i got one in my crib
i got them in all my
uh guest bedrooms i can't get rid of
people anymore
because they love these freaking beds
just go to helixsleep.com
fighter take their two minute sleep quiz
and they will match you with a
customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you well
so don't worry about it helixy is
offering you guys up to 200
off all mattresses orders and uh
free pillows for you guys at
helixsleep.com fighter
that's helix sleep dot com slash fighter
for 200
off uh also while we're being on the
subject of fighting we'll get off how
about ryan garcia dad
said uh manny pacquiao fight is close to
being made the deal is done
exactly what's his dad have to like it
does he is that manager or anything he's
just
no he he's with i mean he has like a man
i don't like that fight for for ryan
yeah i told you yeah
a non-title exhibition oh then that's oh
weak sauce
yeah that's like why is it a uh well
manny pacquiao that's suspect
that's some disowned [ __ ] they're
trying to get their numbers
why yeah why are they doing that they're
trying to get their numbers up that's so
stupid they're both pro boxers why
yeah what do you mean non-title why
would they do an exhibition
why not make it because manny has a belt
dude yeah man he's not he beat
dude keith
i hear you i hear you it's nuts you know
that was three years ago that was two
years ago dude yeah manny's no [ __ ]
punk all right we
haven't seen manny in two years you
wanna bet on that fight i bet
my my i'm a little suspect though that
it's uh oh no
exhibition yeah why isn't it real like
why
why aren't the commissions why aren't
they that's why well well
because manny has belts and they're both
current fighters that's not like retired
fighters but yeah it's not yeah it's not
like manny's not
like if manny took like four years off
that makes sense
but man he's in the run dude like he's
talking about fighting terence crawford
you're talking about earl spence you
talking about all these big fights
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
right who is ryan garcia signed with
golden boy okay who is manny garcia i
mean uh manny pacquiao signed with who
is he with
pbc al haymon yeah golden boy now heyman
beef so therefore it's an exhibition
he mania doesn't have to sign off
because it's it's not
he's not really getting paid like that i
mean he has that that's why
my boxing i'm gonna i got the inside
they basically saying
they can go underneath benny can't have
they haven't they're not
if bob got involved then it'd be for
it'd be real yeah
but bob aaron is not he's with top break
though yeah so i'm saying
the disowned and golden boy they were
like okay cool we'll just have it on our
channel which is weird because even for
manny to do that without his
management it really doesn't work like
that in boxing it's exhibition
it's like a sparring match you listen
you i'm out you ain't getting my money
no you're not paying for it i'd rather
pay for a real fight this is crazy i'm
saying this
i'd rather pay for a real fight and jake
paul been asking because i know it's
real
yeah then this weird kind of
sparring with no head gear yeah we're
not going to hear you that's the way
it's
awesome yeah but maybe he's not going to
come listen that i understand
if that's a real fight if it was a real
fight like keith thurman
you crazy you think ryan garcia gets out
yeah
you're right he get his head knocked off
but again we haven't seen manny in two
years brendan
so okay what makes these guys want to go
after these types of dudes like what
makes ryan want to go
that's a legend i want to fight manny
yeah but like but like
but you guys are saying he's not he he
doesn't have a chance
i don't think right if he's real so what
is
it could be a gentleman's back it's a
win-win situation for ryan if you lose
or you lost to one of the groups
he gets flatlined yeah if that's true
yeah but i don't think if he gets nate
robinson flatlined he's not man panic
pacquiao ain't gonna flatline ryan
garcia
that's juan marquette marquez yeah he
flatlined manny pacquiao
i mean greatest knockout of our time
yeah but that was two like
technical technical like fighters manny
pacquiao is like past his prime we both
can admit
ryan garcia his last fight he beat keith
thurman keith thurman
that's insane bring up keith thurman's
resume
that's it that's such a stupid comment
keith
[ __ ] he ran he run it he running for my
man earl spence
okay he's not signing the fight to
terrence crawford i get it he beat
sean porter he beat danny garcia jenny
garcia not legit
you saw what you're saying remember we
talked about that you said let's go over
this okay
so he beat danny garcia who's a
[ __ ] spencer
sean porter and okay but hold on hold on
that was
that was 30 you know until he lost to
manny pacquiao
yeah wait let's just go down you're
talking about you're talking about a
multiple division
world champion multiple different is he
better aerospace
i don't know i i don't think he's better
than spain okay okay but remember keith
also
was injured yeah but earl space coming
off and got me an
almost fatal car crash yeah but
that's different than the injury that uh
thurman had turmeric yeah
on his shoulder surgery yeah but that's
a common that's what you do
sean porter and danny garcia back to
back okay all right whatever
but also for a he's world title
give that man you can't say he's not
[ __ ] you're right you're right you're
right yeah okay i'm saying manny
pacquiao
that fight by the way honestly that
wasn't the key thurman i know like
manny pacquiao dismantled him that's
what he delivered he delivered yeah
you're right
am i right let me know what i'm crazy
but i'm saying i'm but
this is what i'm saying right here we
haven't seen manny pacquiao in two years
okay that's okay it's manny pacquiao
all right this guy he's he's been
fighting like many pacquiao needs fights
he's old now he can't do that one gear
like remember what connor said
like you just can't dive back into
something and then like yo you think
like these young guys he's young
bro ryan garcia is a young dog you think
he like many people gonna go in there
and just like dismantle yeah
yeah okay so
let's look his last legend like he
didn't lose to jeff horn the teacher he
didn't lose that fight in australia
they robbed him yeah so his last real
loss was to me floyd mayweather
granted he had one arm in that fight
here you go with these excuses that
floyd said y'all was gonna go with
okay i watched that fight okay those are
facts how was that fix
he had one arm he couldn't he could've
posted on the fight but many
many could have postponed that fight and
how mad everybody had been if he
postponed that fight
again again
floyd said it either way even with two
good ones i'm not making an excuse
maybe even with two arms it'd been a
better fight i don't know if
manny wins but i want my [ __ ] money
back
that fight was awful yeah if you were
like i was there if they would have told
us hey you know manny has one arm going
this fight i'm like i'm not paying for
that
of course he's gonna you should be mad
at men he lied to the public i know
well there p there's a lawsuit against
him for it uh-huh
damn okay okay so besides floyd then he
gets knocked out by
like tko by ron juan milwaukee market
dude thousand two on 12
bubba
he he beat chris algieri he's no punk
flat floyd with one arm dude beat
timothy bradley a lot of people don't
think you won that fight all right
either way he won that fight timothy
bradley jesse vargas no punk jeff horn
beat him
dude matissi's no punk at all that is
true beat
your boy adrian broner that's your boy
adrian adrian
dude his stepfather let's go let's go
through his last three fights okay
compared to ryan garcia's last three
fights okay batisi
broner keith thurman okay get the [ __ ]
out of my face
that's insane that matisse is the one i
respect for real what's he saying dude
he knocked him out he knocked about but
broner's no punk he's so talented ever
since she got her case
ever since he got knocked out by marco's
madonna he don't throw any punches now
let's
let's look at ryan garcia's last three
okay let's go ahead luke campbell
you mostly you've just heard of luke
campbell if you're not
francisco fan fonska
there you go but look look look i get it
he's not fighting anyone
but look at how he's knocking them out
if they're not if this is a mismatch
i don't want to see any rounds first
round knockout first round knockout
seven round knockout second round
knockout like if they don't belong in
the ring with you
knock him out and that's what he's doing
i agree
and that's what young prospects do thank
you you said i'm saying some
young prospects to get a night where
he's like oh he didn't look good and he
fought a tomato king i didn't think he
looked good against luke campbell
i think well because he got knocked down
in the second round well he always
fights with his chin up so eventually
someone's going to
what do you think's going to happen if
manny pacquiao lands out many pack
houses
yeah man pacquiao knocks dudes out bro
do you think he'll be
competitive i think so you think so i
don't think it's like gonna be a
uh uh a tko if it's a real fight i think
man they would stop him but if it's
competitive then that's why they should
probably sanction it if it was something
like crazy like you know i'm so again
i understand you're saying that
skeptical hippolyze that's not
sanctioned
yeah that's weird man you're talking
about two i mean they're in there
they're doing
they did it yeah why is it not real
because
you said boxing is ran by promotional
companies crazy so yeah
i don't want to see the it's not real
[ __ ] it don't make way more money if it
was
an actual boxing game no no no one's
going to respect that win
let's say ryan garcia wins by decision
no one respects that how it's not real
belts aren't on the line manny pacquiao
put your big boy boots on fight a real
fight
manny pacquiao probably was like i've
been off for two years this young buck
is knocking everyone out give me someone
easy first did i probably no wait man
do you manny [ __ ] back down i know
you keep saying that he's been off man
to ever do against ryan garcia right now
hold on he can do it i believe it i
believe in man no no let me just set
that let me just set the plate for
brenden and listen what he's saying
adrian brandy pacquiao his last three
wins matisse
you're telling me though yeah you're
telling me right now adrien broner
wouldn't beat ryan garcia
no adrian not beating you you believe in
rangers and i love adrian i age you
believe in him a lot
no i don't you believe in reinger he
gets you beats matissi
yeah no no that's a competitive fight
it's a close fight but even with that
that says a lot about ryan
yeah you believe a ton and right tank
knocks out ryan
danny heamy beats ryan in the boxing
match tofido lopez
kills ryan i don't think ryan is a great
fighter i'm just saying
manny pacquiao is oh he's 40 what 42 41
and still killing it
okay been on for two years you haven't
heard from manny pacquiao so the fact
that he's off for two
years fighting a young buck who's like
knocking everyone out all right
you're full of confidence you think he's
gonna go in there and just like yo
[ __ ] with manny pacquiao he gonna
kill manny no
chance all right from a to you from a
two-year break not a chance
okay all right no chance because how
long did mary take off when he beat
keith thurman oh yeah go back to that
it wasn't that long dude do you talk
about keith cause he fought he fought
he's
thurman he fought adrian broner that
same year
look at the same year so hard but he
took four years off
when did he take four years off i'm
sorry he took how long off he didn't
take he took a long time off after
matissi
he took a yeah he took a year off after
the jeff horn
loss really won that fight and then
fought matisse after a year off and beat
him stopped him in seven rounds doug
for a world title okay hold on here's
the thing and then a year later
okay fought so he's having a long layoff
years off all right
took a year off then fought adrian
broner beat him took another
you know took a hot second off then beat
keith thurman let me counter that
argument
he's only 40 by the way okay he's four
okay any small 40. he's a small 40.
let's let's just
i love how you bro he take a year off
matisse
he fought matisse at a welter like he's
a bigger matisse is a small guy
and he fights naturally at 140. he
fought manny pacquiao at 147
and let's be honest he comes forward and
he's just a heavy-handed and he's slow
manny pacquiao dismantle that style any
day of the week
so that year off can be it comes with
the little complex
mysterious ways that okay you don't see
that now
the next fight adrian broner that was a
great fight for
manny pacquiao he just over dismantled
him because he's in rhythm now
boom then he fights keith thurman later
on that year in rhythm
and kills him so you mean tell me he's
not in rhythm so you think he's off
really bro he's off
two years okay and ryan garcia you we
just
knock out knockout knockout he's full of
confidence he wants this
i see what he's saying he struggled luke
campbell
yeah but you're telling me if manny
doesn't hit him with the same shot he's
you think he's getting up you don't
think manny pacquiao hits harder than
luke
he does but that's what the gym is for
now he knows where i can get touched at
now and he's southpaws just like luke
campbell he's oh i'm gonna be ready for
that shot
and and let's uh lou kemba is way taller
than manny pacquiao
so maybe i caused faster better footwork
yeah better boxer who has whoever
ryan garcia will have more reach he's
developing a jab i like what i saw later
rounds listen that's the heart of a
champion he got knocked down in the
second round he could have got up he got
back up and stopped the guy
and i bet it against him i was like oh i
see something but even you're skeptical
of the stop i'm not skeptical of the
stop but
manny pacquiao reached man he has small
arms
why wouldn't it pop up right away um
either 67 inches
and then go to ryan garcia and go 70.
not crazy
okay look at that look at that look at
the height look at the height uh chin
five five go to that's what that's what
he's five five yeah this one man it's
tiny
this one manny pac-man that's what he
does okay five ten he five ten brian
garcia the
the tallest guy he fought was uh what's
the guy named who patted his gloves i
can't think of uh his name um margarito
margarito
the tallest guy and ryan and he comes in
and he shields up and what do you do to
margarita and he did he what are you
doing margarita okay he killed him what
are you doing
he killed margarita pissed him off
exactly but margarito is like
the same ryan garcia is a boxer he's a
mover he comes forward he throws
he's way faster who's faster man manny
manny pacquiao or ryan garcia
manny pacquiao brandon
100 percent inside the ring now on
youtube and clips on instagram
probably ryan garcia garcia is lightning
fast in the ring
first round knockout first round
knockout against nobody i don't give a
[ __ ] dude
he's fighting nobody all right all right
the great manny pacquiao
i'm i just want you to hear what you're
saying one time one time you're saying
uh manny pacquiao's fast from ryan
gerstein okay inside the ring
okay inside three again he his last
fight was keeping
keith sermon i hear what you're saying
right now you don't think he
thurman beats luke campbell easy yes
easy yes
you think luke campbell beats uh porter
no you think luke campbell beats adrian
broner
good fight but look what he did there
but brendan he's listening he's
listening lou campbell is a small guy
he listen guys it's like 147. once away
sorry you go down a little bit
name someone in their weight class i'm
saying man okay
all right to just discount manny
pacquiao i'm not discounting them but
you discount ryan garcia like
i'm just not sold on him yet to fight
these big boys
but but as a as a he has a belt well him
and devin hanley have the same thing
there's a million belts it's a million
bucks
okay okay nothing this guy was like
here's a belt
listen you know how will you knock
someone out everybody getting belts you
know when you knock someone out and
everyone is like you on that cloud line
you want to call out he called out tank
i can't get tanked
i want manny pacquiao manny pacquiao i
was like why couldn't he get tanked
well because promotion again promotional
no adria or
tank wanted the fight yeah but you know
it's easy his promotions
he worked his promotional company you
know why you know why
they said they said that's for tank
davis hey what kill him
destroy him i know what about lopez he
killed me nobody talked about lopez
well tank's talking about tank one thing
because well that makes sense yeah tang
lopez makes sense david
wants the rental come get it david healy
want that smoke do you think devon
he beats tank hell no no way but it was
oh so
can i tell you lopez was on food start i
lopez
was on food truck and he was like tank's
easy work man
which is well you know they grew up and
they said they grew up in the gate but
but tank took it easy on uh uh lopez
because you know he's younger than uh
lopez said he
beat him up his clips online that tank
is he's getting now but let me can i
tell you a story once
i'm here man so i saw devin healy right
so he comes in haney don't throw it
there's no ellen hey we pulled devon
right
now definitely he's a [ __ ] let's
now do real quick before your story okay
devin haney lopez tank okay garcia yeah
who has the least skill out of those
four that's not fair though
i'm just saying who has lee skill of
course you gonna say ryan garcia but
there you go oh but but
now hold on it's not fair no no but why
is it not fair garcia has more fights
than lopez professionally
can okay listen you putting in these top
these guys are beasts
they're naturally gifted this guy that's
who ryan wants to fight yeah now if you
come to me and go ryan's fight another
prospect i'm signing with ryan i'm gonna
talk about the creme de la creme
ryan's just not there yet right they
want to push him like he is
but ryan just got with a professional
team canelo he's been training in
victorville in a garage that's how he
blew up he doesn't have like his skill
where he doesn't have
the the background as these amateur
fighters like my fault
no i get to i get what you're saying but
i'm saying ryan garcia and manny
pacquiao
and he's on cloud nine and what's the
real team we'll see okay put a grand on
it
on what put a grain on ryan garcia oh
pacquiao i'll put that
crazy i'll put that up i will put that
up bring it now bring it in
if it's a real fight now if it's like on
thriller with a trillo
[Applause]
music video no if it's a legit
sanctioned fight yeah i'll bet you that
all right
all right now i wanna i don't wanna just
hope is like this exhibition don't go
through i'm like yo fight for real for
real yeah i need a real
well you gonna better grant a hundred
percent he must keep tripping
really i guarantee you ryan ryan garcia
over manny pacquiao over manny pacquiao
in a real fight who's been on for two
years
yes yes a hundred percent a healthy
manny pacquiao this guy just got one
wild
guy this guy just fought in a
championship fight
and he and granny he didn't go to the
championship great
he didn't look great he came back and
knocked him out if he didn't look it was
not you didn't watch them like oh
that's the next big thing what did he
show you he showed you heart
confidence and he showed you power in
the late rounds that's all i need for
you i saw a slow left hook
you know that left hook was so low you
said it was fast where you were you
i didn't i know i was like that left
hook is not hitting when we watch i was
like that left hook
when he knocked him off body shot was
dope okay but uh when he kept going up
top
it was not there it would be better it'd
be there for
manny pacquiao you're insane hey look
let me tell you a story real quick and
i'm gonna tell you
we'll get off it so yeah let's hear it
devon you know so tank was it was wasn't
all in the doghouse tank was running
through these guys
and tell the listener what the dog house
is at floyd so floyd mayweather's boxing
gym
uh the dog house is it was sparring
matched with like unlimited time there's
no time so yeah
they they find out like the heart of the
heart buddy yeah so it's like mostly
black
african-american fighters we're around
the ring we beat like this on the side
it's
so intense it's so intense so they're
like it's me anxiety watching we talk we
talk [ __ ] so you will talk [ __ ] till you
like get you off the gate trying to
break you totally you're trying to
trying to break it yeah yeah yeah okay
okay so it was the day where tank was
just like breaking one everyone down
yeah and he was like man no one wanted
to spar tank
floyd was with uh devon at the time he
and
they called him and it was like yo uh
hey man tank talking [ __ ] he was like no
wants to spare him in this weight class
and floyd's like i got someone in the
car with me right now
and then uh steven haney it was devin
and then so he was like you walked to
the gym pulled up to the gym
now devin henry dad is the real legit
dude he's a real one like a real
hardcore he was like man
hey ain't gonna be no spawning we
talking my dog house put money up
so they was like oh [ __ ] everyone's like
now i put put money up on tank man
they're gonna get killed so it was like
put they were betting like stacks like
ten thousand fifteen thousand twenty i
swear to god no headgear no hair no it
wasn't
yeah so but no no time limit so it's
like no
rounds it's like dog house fight to the
death right kind of thing but these are
prospects at the time
so they're like oh it's money involved
oh turn the clock off everybody start
beating all that other stuff floyd right
there entertaining he's like i'll put my
money on tank
right yeah we put money in the tank
right
get in the dog house and man you're not
gonna say devon beat him
no he devon bro no he did it devin's
dead
yeah for sure yeah okay yeah and
everyone who can was there they can
confirm it
like yo devin put it on tank that put it
on man
devin put it on tank devon's a real one
devon put it on tank though
yeah i don't know the story out there i
swear to god i swear to god how long did
they
the only person that had was filming was
uh you know elizabeth
they usually say camera's off too dirty
yeah yeah but that's what i'm saying ely
uh
that guy like ely said back how did
devon put it on him
hold on is this uh devin just like kept
body
like bro tank was just like in the
corner yeah and he kept holding him and
he was like nah nah let me let him go
let him go until
the um one of the trainers got in the
ring tank wasn't landing
wasn't landing anything i'm talking
about no no no no early rounds like
haney was that good bro listen the guy
works hard
like skill like the dude is i never but
again he won't do that in real life in a
real fight but he knows
but yeah he's real he showed me he
showed me something yeah
and listen have you ever done the
doghouse thing hell yeah
hell yeah she was so interested you know
something like that my first yeah
they talk it's not that we do no time in
mma they call it the shark tank
so we're getting ready for a fight love
that shirt like i stay in
and then there's a new guy every fresh
round so you go five rounds
you still get your minute break we go
five rounds and i stay in and a new
fresh
fighter comes every round are you
serious talking about killers
yeah wrestling killers no mma mma mma
small gloves killers you don't get no
break no break
nah five rounds but hold on it was a and
you you knew you were gonna do it you'd
have like the worst
[ __ ] anxiety really i used to hate it
so how many like what was it it would be
it'd be like shane carowind rashad
evans cody donald elliot just monsters
and they're just watching you and by
that fourth round you're exhausted well
how many days a week did you do that oh
man
just once oh okay once once once a week
once a camp once a camp once again that
is stressful
does it could be like wrestle until
someone's wear out then the next one
come in is that
don't do that they'll break them yeah in
wrestling we used to do that you go till
some guy breaks
oh okay and how many times do you do
that we do that all the time oh okay
gotcha
yeah so that's like y'all version of the
dog yeah and you and you've done the
doghouse yeah i was like this is so
stressful it's stressful yeah
i mean it was it was fun with your
friends it's i love when i fought new
guys who was like new to the yeah
because all the homies that like they
talk [ __ ] and beat it yeah and when you
land a punch it's like a
rap battle you know how like when a a
bar doesn't land
tank getting ready for my ben rothwell
fight and shane carl when he was the
heavyweight champ yeah
came in the third round and dude knocked
straight up knocked me out
wait wait what and then they like picked
me back up and i kept going
and then like what the [ __ ] my fight was
the next weekend so i went in that fight
everyone's like oh you barely got hits
like yeah i got knocked out the week
before
[ __ ] wait hold on that's like what the
anthony joshua with the andy
ruiz what fight he got knocked out
sparring you can't say nothing you can't
be like you know after the
the post fight came back oh well i got
knocked out last week you know what
i [ __ ] up this no you just gotta eat
it [ __ ]
hey man it's 20 21 and maybe self
anxiety maybe you're still talking to
your bum ass friends about your problems
just quit doing that talk to somebody
who knows what they're talking about
there's better help right something is
interfering with your happiness
preventing you from achieving your goals
well guess what
better help is here to help you they
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed
professional therapist forget the chat
rooms forget the forums forget the
instagram comments
dude get with a real professional who
can start
communicating under 48 hours not crisis
line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online
all right the service available
worldwide logging your account anytime
send a message your counselor
your timely thoughtful response plus you
can schedule weekly videos which i
suggest you do or phone sessions however
you want to get it done
better help us commit to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change cancer if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
also available for those that need it
better help once you start living a
happier life
today visit betterhelp.com fighter
that's better h-e-l-p and join the over
1 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health with the help of
an
experienced professional talking about
real
counsels here son this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp so
you guys the fire and kids listeners get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
fighter that's betterhelp.com fighter
maz what's going on brother how are you
i'm great man it's good to see you good
to see you man i love this setup i never
i've never been in here so this is
your first time huh it's my first time
man last time i saw you you and i were
doing stand-up at the laugh factory i
had to
follow you and it was a nightmare you
know brendan nightmare
once i take down my pants and people
have seen that i'm just heart falling
hard like that's a small penis
they're still talking you're on stage
like hey i got jokes that was a small
penis
you know it's funny you say that gosh
man well thanks man first of all
uh i i was look i i scroll through
photos sometimes
and it was march 12th and it was
interesting because
last year around this time you and i saw
each other on a plane
and as i was uh i remember i had all
these dates lined up and people were
always like i was talking to paul virzi
and we're like
are you gonna be doing your days we're
like yeah because the government hasn't
said anything
and the government didn't say anything
it took like it took
the nba a private enterprise
to shut that [ __ ] down before we all
started showing you that seriously yes
yes i remember i was on a plane i was
headed to new orleans i'm
on the plane and it's when everything's
starting to get hectic
and i'm like are we i'm text my my age
i'm like are you sure i'm good to do
this
because like a theater of 800 people
he's like yeah you're good man you're
good
and then uh my brother who's my road
manager goes
hey bert just canceled i'm like bert
krei sure did
like birch is cancelled he's in new
orleans same night different theater
different venue he just canceled like
something's going on here dude so i text
my manager i'm like dude are you 100
sure i'm good to go and he goes well
we're playing by air i just got off the
plane play by air
yeah i'm out they see that's the part
that's the problem is and and we can go
back and i don't know what your guys
politics are it doesn't matter the point
is
we look to our leadership to go
at some point to go listen this shit's
serious we're gonna lock that [ __ ] down
the problem
the problem is it wasn't clear like the
information from the top
officials whether it's newsom even
fouchy
yeah who you know fauci to trump to to
our leaders
it was just like you you have to kind of
like
shuffle through all this [ __ ] but we
didn't it was like so
but that's important you think but
that's what we didn't know like nothing
was clear
the point is look when you come to my
comedy show you're going to count on me
jokes being funny i'm going to deliver
i'm going to have energy i'm there every
night i'm gonna do it there's no
confusion
okay so we also look to our cd cdc
i did i've had a guy on my podcast who
is uh um
you know a journalist who was who was uh
uh
studying all the epidemiology and all
that stuff he'd done all the reporting
and he was he was trying to you know
tell us an analogy he goes cdc
is the new york yankees of disease
control like meaning like they are
supposed to be the best of the best yes
and so we look at you look at the best
of the best and you go
all right are we gonna lock it down or
not but it falls on two comics talking
and going are you gonna do your dates
this weekend
i don't know i'm not sure how many
people we had no idea yeah
well the nation didn't either and it was
like well this state's locked down this
one's not that's what's crazy eating
this restaurant not in this city
look dude i'm like wait i just want one
blanket like tell me what to do
but know your [ __ ] don't tell me wear
masks don't wear a mask straight up you
need to
listen again monday monday morning
quarterbacking but still you need to
have your leadership from the federal
government needs to step up and be like
yo
we're not sure what's going on but we're
just right now straight up let's just
cancel for everybody
hey brandon cancer you can't because we
don't know moss can't see a gig we don't
know we're figuring this out yes as
opposed to leaving it up to us so you
and i march 12
were at the comedy store great time and
at the laugh factory
and it was interesting because they had
gone to the thing of like 50 50-person
capacity
yep that was what it was in the comments
the comments and the factory both of
them
okay and people it was funny because
people were all nervous nobody knew
what's going on it was like
and then and it got a laugh because you
go on stage i went on stage i was like
are we supposed to be here yeah and
they're all laughing i was like you guys
don't give a [ __ ] like nobody and and
like you said we had a great time i have
that picture of you and me just right
there
not knowing what's coming man who knew
who knew
but i think the other thing that was
confusing especially even now it's like
for us
to look at the leaders and the
leadership in the government
and you know you can look at the
approval rating of our leadership our
government it's so down because we don't
trust it
because you see newsom yeah it's like is
it this serious because he's in a
restaurant
right he didn't shut down his vineyard
he's like he's out and about yeah so
i know he's shutting down all the small
businesses but then he's okay
well what i do is i'm i'm a person of
like i err on the side of caution so i'm
sitting there going like all right even
if this guy
says shut it down then he goes to a
restaurant himself i go look this is
pretty legit like you
you can look at a fauci and be like you
know people always argue well he didn't
say we're mass in the beginning
well you look at him and he goes well
the data was coming in number one number
two we didn't want everyone going and
taking the n95s the way they were taking
all the toilet paper
and then the medical people don't have
mass that's the other thing i say
our country tell us that but don't let
us find that out
second hand from like tmz because it's
like we don't trust you but listen but
listen here's the problem
and i i don't again i don't know where
you guys fall on it i definitely am left
leaning when it comes to my politics
and i feel like there was a lot of
anti-science
in the previous administration to the
point where scott atlas shows up
and he's like let's just do her immunity
and then someone's like well
if you do the math that's like two three
million people gotta die before we just
get there
without all of these one percent of
three million yeah whatever it is right
300 million yeah
so whatever it is so so i i feel like
um um you know the the the problem was a
lack of leadership
and and that again goes back to look we
can't but here's my thing
you but lack of leadership 100 i'm with
you and it was super
deluded and there's like this weird gray
area which we're locked
down but we don't know why we're wearing
masks some aren't wearing masks
but if you tell me if give give me a
reason why and i'm on board but if you
just say do this
and don't give us a reason and i don't
trust you in the first place it's hard
to it's hard but see that's the problem
because i think the left and right
isn't straight well listen the problem
is what you just said is is when you
find out things like when you see
newsome at the restaurant you see pelosi
getting the hair thing done you go oh my
god like are
they taking it seriously or not but what
you just said you have
you guys are smart enough to be able to
look at
and be critical thinkers and go all
right you know what yes i wasn't
trusting it before now the data says
you know obviously it's basic logic
stay far from each other the odds of you
getting that guy's spit in your face
are gonna be diminished put a mask on
the odds are gonna be diminished it's
just basic logic yes
and and the problem becomes where you're
right
we have this skepticism in our head and
now we're going like who's telling the
truth who's not
but that goes back to what i would say
my number one issue
with trump as president was a lot of
people voted for him
because they were like we want an
outsider we want someone who doesn't we
don't want a politician we don't want
we want someone who comes from and i
said that's and i said in my in my
my netflix special my previous special i
was like this is the only
thing in the world where people go i
want an outsider you never go to get an
operation and go i want a guy who's
never done
surgery to operate on my eye right yeah
and and so we see what happens when you
bring in an outsider because i don't
know about you guys but i'll be honest
with you listen i'm not saying biden is
perfect but i will tell you man ever
since
these guys have come in america's
chilled out i've breathed their sigh of
relief i agree
dude first of all we were under four
years i feel like we were bombarded by
trump's again i don't care if you like
him or not you have to admit every
morning
he'd wake up 10 tweets 20 tweets so it
was like it was like the game tetris
it's unprofessional the the blocks are
coming and you're like oh my god
and i go these past two weeks i've been
so happy to wake up and just listen to
just just real news they're like oh
there's global warming i'm like
yes there it is there's a pandemic yes
we're gonna die
but like a lot of comics and like a lot
of those late night uh
hosts what are you gonna do now what are
they gonna do now oh
you know are you gonna still do trump
bibs no no listen like that's your game
let me tell you something because again
as someone who's on the left and i'm an
iranian american i'm an immigrant right
and my mom first of all a lot of iranian
americans turned around and liked trump
including my own mother that was an
interesting one so it was funny because
when
trump when biden won i called my mom
like did you see he won and she's like
well
now what are you gonna make jokes about
i was like you too mom you're you're
coming at me
right now right now but the truth is i
listen man
i i was doing jokes i i'm i'm i'm
happy to go back to talking about my
kids
by the way biden's going to do [ __ ] that
we're going to make fun of right yeah
and people always say they always go
people ask me to go trump must have been
good for comedy i go [ __ ] no
because two reasons number one he said
so much crazy [ __ ]
it was never you you could never keep up
with him right
he'd say one thing i remember he was
like little rocky man i need a little
rocking man joke pocahontas i need a
pocahontas joke storm me down i need
stormy daniel's joke and you go on and
on and on
and you can't keep up with the guy so
that was number one and everyone's doing
it
and everyone's doing it but you know you
got your point of view on it but it's
like
as if you're a touring comedian if
you're not a late night
host who's got riding team and going
today trump said and let's go down it's
hard to keep up if you're a comedian
who's going to spend a year
working on your hour and then go do that
hour and you do that hour
and then people watch it they're like
wait when did trump say rocket man
oh that was before the timing is over
and before
it's done too hard to keep up that's
number one the second thing that
nobody talks about and i felt it
firsthand and i don't know brendan if
you ever talk if you guys ever talk
about
um uh uh trump in your stand up or not
but i stay away from that
i'm very political because again coming
from immigrant background i'm like i
gotta talk about this right
if it's your thing yeah double down i
have to
and so and so it was interesting because
as much as people go oh he was good for
comedy
i realized once she's gone i realized
that i had a certain level of anxiety
because people got so sensitive
to trump jokes trump supporters so
before trump became president when he
was just the host
of the apprentice i would do trump jokes
people would chuckle
life goes on once he starts running for
president start saying some racist [ __ ]
jim's personal
start saying some other [ __ ] people come
on board and they go yeah i love it he's
saying what he's saying what he
he means what he means yeah and then you
do a joke
and people start yelling at you in the
audience so i
i felt like there was a certain level of
anxiety anytime i would because the way
i would do my show is i would do like
kid kid kid material
now i'm going to my trump jokes so i
would kind of like me too
put my toe in by going all right guys
i'm about to do
some trump jokes you know you all need
to calm the [ __ ] down
i'm not making fun of your grandmother
yeah my own mother's a trump supporter
i've had to deal with this [ __ ] so just
relax
and i'm gonna do some jokes about trump
and i might even have somebody jokes
just
just calm down yep and i swear to god
even when you do that sometimes
still they still get weird does this get
so that
causes anxiety for me like why is it as
a comedian i need
in america why is it as a comedian in
america i'm not i'm not in
you know some despotic country in some
you know some far-off land where they go
don't make fun of the king
yeah you're not north korea i'm not in
north korea right
i'm in the united states where we're
supposed to as an audience member you're
supposed to come and be like
you know that was you know i didn't find
that funny but i'm not going to yell i'm
not going to lose my mind
so i had that anxiety going the whole
time and i still like when i when i
slowly put my toe into the trump water
i'm still
it's it's become a cult in a way in that
it's fine to be a support i love barack
obama but you come and tell me hey
barack obama
uh under barack obama there was the the
most drone attacks
ever than any previous president i'll be
like you're right he wasn't perfect he
did some bachelors yeah whatever
president you side with
i can pick apart some of it it's just
that comes with the two and you gotta
and that's what america is about is we
should laugh at our
leader we can we can make fun of our
leaders why because we're supposed to
expose their hypocrisy whether it's
gavin newsom yes or nancy pelosi or
donald trump
we should be able to be like wait a
minute you're going to the restaurant
tell me and i can't go you're going to
the restaurant
you understand what i'm saying so as
much as people go oh what are you going
to talk about now
he was you know he was good for comedy i
go man i feel the level of anxiety that
guy caused me
in my day-to-day and then even in
stand-up it's just it was nice it wasn't
worth it
yeah no how old are your kids uh i got a
10 year old daughter and a 12 year old
son
oh damn you're in it yeah i got a five
he'll be five in february and a
one-year-old
oh that's adorable man the best two boys
dude it's the best kids are the best and
we just got a pandemic puppy as well i
was never a dog person
just got the dog and there you go a
golden doodle
oh those are she's adorable my brother
sleeps with them
you have kids you have dogs i mean no
dogs i want dogs my girl
doesn't want dogs she doesn't want dogs
are a beast man she doesn't want the
responsibility
well you know it's a lot i will tell you
once your kid's a little bit older kids
love
them love them and and if you get like
if if you go and get
you know you can do your research a
little bit see which ones are which we
got we got the golden doodle simply
because
uh she's hypoallergenic yeah they don't
shed too they don't shed and my daughter
had some allergies and stuff so we're
like all right you know what let's let's
go ahead and do it a dog in the pandemic
though it's probably the best time to do
it because you don't have to leave it at
home
well that's with it 24 7. yeah i was
nervous just like your
your your lady is that because i've
never had a dog and i was like oh my god
never we had a dog once for two days
yeah that's right
no because we come from an immigrant
background yeah so when i would tell my
dad i want a dog i want a dog he didn't
understand what that meant and like
and the iranian culture listen a lot of
immigrants don't
like dogs aren't big in a lot of
immigrant cultures like in iran
dogs are known to be like they say
nadjes which means
um like dirty like you're not supposed
to like there's wild dogs running on the
streets
yeah yeah of course in the past 40 years
i'm sure it's changed a lot but when i
was a kid that's how it was
and so when i'd be like i want to die i
want to die my dad's like no no and then
finally when i was i don't know how old
i was but
he went to his friend who had two dogs
that had grown up together
and he's like give me your give me one
of those dogs this shows you the
mentality of like
yeah the macho man immigrant mentality
where there's no like let me do the
research
find out if it's okay to separate a
brain
yeah let me have one for my son and the
other guy's like sure take him
bro he was with us for 48 hours he was
the most depressed dog
he wanted to go home he get me out of
here
what do you want to know where'd you
find this dog
let's go he's writing in the journal so
sad
very emo very emotional
yeah so so that was um that's all i had
and then so this time around my wife and
kids were like looking at golden doodles
labradoodles all that
and it's funny because like you just
said i kept saying i was like i don't
know guys i don't know
finally we were sitting there one time
in just front of the tv and she's all
over the instagram
doodle pages and she's like hey there's
a dog available should we get him
get her and i was like i don't know if
it's the right time she's like you
always say it's not the right time
and then i was like why are you asking
me when you already know the answer
and we went and got her and man it's the
sweetest thing in the world you love it
i love this stuff man she's so dope are
you kids in school
my kids are doing the zoom school oh
nothing worse these poor kids
i feel so bad for them but i will tell
you they've been thriving under it and
really yeah both of my kids first of all
they're in private schools that have
done a great job of handling it i can't
believe your private school's not open
well no they're they're they're staying
you know they they go by all the
guidelines and all that stuff
and and i've run into friends of mine
who are like yeah my my kids in public
school and
the teacher shows up for one hour a week
and then i got to teach the rest of the
week i'm like
different you get what you pay for yeah
no but my kids have done a pretty good
job my daughter is constantly like
so we got a second floor upstairs all i
hear is like jumping up and down she's
constantly like doing dance contests and
stuff
um just what i don't know what they do
she's just like i just hear her i'm like
our roof's gonna fall like i go i go she
in a dance school what's she doing
um and then my son is a big dungeons and
dragons guy so he's been running d
d stuff out of his room a little bit uh
nerdy kid
he's actually they may call you son of
nerdy definitely no yeah
he's not throwing a football around no
no no he's outside
no no he's actually a really good
athlete yeah but
choose be honest with you yeah i i love
you don't even understand dude
this this hit me one time when i was
doing shows at the san jose improv
okay i'm walking around with with my
friends and we go on the campus of san
jose state university
and they happen to have a robotics
competition where these
these kids have built robots and the
whole game of the robot game is like
there's a ball
and these guys with their robots they're
all nerdy they're like got their robots
and the robots picking up the ball and
running it and throwing it into the
net and these guys you know and and then
we walk out and we happen to overhear
some conversations and these kids are
like
high school kids 16 you know 15 16 and
they're all like yeah you know i said i
thought that i think
you know i thought the the the mechanism
that we had going was
quite appropriate right i think and i
overheard them and i turn to my friends
and go oh my god lord let my kids be
like these kids
like they're not somewhere hanging out
at 7-eleven asking for some dude to be
like hey can you buy me some beer
which is the kind of [ __ ] we were doing
me too yeah i'm
dude i was all for it so as much as like
what you just said might
you know the but you know both kids are
somewhat
you know they're athletic but i'm
leaning and no nerds run the world
i'm leaning into that i want that little
elon musk i want that little jeff bezos
i want the kid that i don't have to
because you think about yourself like
it's a miracle
that some of us when you start talking
to you about like your your your
your youth it's a miracle that we're
still here nuts but the world's
different
too though but we did stupid [ __ ] like
we were like 16 years old i remember
there was a
volkswagen fox which is like a jetta but
uh like a jetta on a diet it's like yeah
super skinny the front's more narrow
small like you could
like you could probably pick up the
volkswagen fox this
no that's a newer one no no yeah that
one right there that one right there
that one the fox see that thing you see
how small
yeah so that's the 1990 that's about the
car we had
my friend had that car and look it's a
and i think it was very it was probably
this one it's
like you got you got a two seat you know
two door and then so
i remember specifically six of us in
that car
coming home from a party in uh uh on
like in the back woods of marin county
where you go like to like stinson beach
and
mere beach and stuff great it's all
windy roads two lane
and i'm pretty sure the guy driving it
had been drinking too y'all speed
but we got the music blaring and we're
in the bag every turn we're like
yeah listen stupid
stupid stupid and lucky to be here and
you want you want your kid in his
basement playing dungeons and dragons i
want my kid being like dad i
got a dungeon
you don't even know bro i sometimes when
he talks to me i don't even know what
he's talking about he's like you know
i'm i'm i'm the
dm i go dm what's that like you direct
message someone no i'm a dungeon master
[Applause]
by the way one of my neighbors down the
street and it's been announced
his name is jonathan goldstein he's the
he and john daly they are the um
they they wrote and directed game night
and the new vacation these guys have
done a lot of stuff they have
written and will be directing a dungeons
and dragons movie with chris pine
oh wow because there was one they did
it went really bad right they did it
this is this is like a big this one's a
big deal
so it's coming up and and um and it is
it's huge
and like guys like um i'll tell you
who's doing it is uh
vin vin diesel plays dungeons and
dragons
we love them our boy uh uh uh who was
sophia vergara's husband what's his name
again oh
joe joe yeah no no
mijello mangelo yeah yeah he's a big d i
mean these
d is back there he is manginello he's a
great guy um he was it was actually
interesting
he was on colbert and and i i i'm a fan
of joe's and i'm a fan of stephen
colbert's
and i tried to watch it because i was
like it's gonna be interesting
they started talking d i had no idea
there it is yeah there it is look at him
yeah he's a stud yeah yeah i like him so
all of that there's a geeks out over
dungeons right yeah so it's back
and as a father and i don't know how you
think but as a father i actually
because my parents began being immigrant
parents they were like
i looked at you guys i look at the asian
history you're not talking about right
that's a fair guess what kind of what
kind of what's your background uh
vietnamese vietnamese what's your
background korea korea okay you know
what somebody yeah
immigrant parents do not want comedian
right now they want lawyer doctor
engineer 100
we came all the way from another country
get your ass over to get your education
and i want to be able to say my son the
doctor my daughter the doctor i want to
be able to say we talked about it many
times on the show too dude so that's
part of it right
so they pushed me in such a direction
now brendan how old were you when you
started doing stand-up
uh one of my 37 so i've been
almost six years so 31 so you start even
later than me how old were you when you
started
i was what three years ago okay
seven twenty seven and a half three
twenty three years so i started 26.
and that's late right that's late i like
it i look at guys like like i remember
hearing dane cook talk about 17.
chappelle 14.
yeah when i was 17 i wanted to do it i
was doing plays in my school
my teachers all said you're good at it
my teachers would i
used to do i was doing a i was doing a
play i think it was junior high school
my parents came to watch it you know
these immigrant parents they show up
they got the suit on first of all
they think it's a [ __ ] copacabana or
something
i'm the fourth lead in the middle school
man
they showed up in the suit and then the
director like you know
after the show the director's being nice
and she's talking to my parents he's
like
you know your son has the has the the it
factors it
yeah you do this and my parents oh thank
you thank you we get in the car my dad's
like that [ __ ] is crazy
so i mean i was like oh my gosh so i got
i got
sidetracked for a long time and that's
why it was 26 when i finally did it
so because of that with my kids i tell
them guys if you find a passion
run with it i'm with you a hundred
percent so when i see this kid do d and
d
i'm all about it yeah i will tell you
the other day i had that moment in my
head where i was like i gotta ask him i
like what what's the end
i was like buddy can i just ask you a
question about dnd he's like sure i go
when you do d d like does it is it
exercising your creativity
yeah is it kind of like just passing
times in my mind i'm hoping he goes
yeah dad we create it i go okay and he
said he goes he goes they create the
world i go
all right okay so i'm thinking to myself
maybe he'll be like a uh
what is it rr martin or jeremiah the guy
who wrote the game of thrones book
george
maybe he'll just write that maybe he'll
write game of thrones or something lower
the ring
yeah in my mind that's what i figured
you know i was like
you know yeah that's a long shot but you
know it's tough yeah with
with my kid uh tiger he yeah he'll be
five in february because you know
my fight background sports background so
i'll watch fighting sports
and i'll go dad boom boom pow and i
always want to fight like but you're not
gonna do like i know you
enjoy it with your dad but you're not
gonna do this yeah the kids don't grow
up in this house and fight in in the
cage
yeah yeah that's not what that's not how
it is it's it's an interesting it's an
interesting journey we go through
because like you just said you
want your kid i mean that's all you want
you want your kid just be passionate
about whatever it is
and again when you think about the kind
of stuff you did you worry about your
kid because
oh god but also you crawl i don't mean
interrupt you but also
like i made some sacrifices and crawl
through some [ __ ] and have ct
so you don't have to do this absolutely
but if you choose to do it then you're
gonna do it you know what i'm saying
there's nothing you do
my dad didn't want me to fight my dad
didn't want me to do stand up
if their heart is set on they're gonna
do it and you better jump on for the
ride and that's the beauty if you're
lucky enough to have a passion about
something
i always tell people i go you find that
passion go for it whatever that passion
is that's when it gets tricky if they
don't
have something they want to do like a
passion that's where they get into drugs
exactly exactly and it's and it's and
it's a you know i think
i always help i remind comedians we are
very lucky
to have found our passion yes and so
number one if you can find your passion
you're you're part of the elite group of
people in the world who
know what they want to do if you're able
to make a living doing that passion
now you're a boy you know super elite
yeah you know because
and then i run into people a lot of
times who go i don't know like i'm stuck
and i don't know what what to do
and i go okay go back to what you used
to do as a child what did you used to do
you used to play baseball
well um maybe you should go try to see
if you can become a baseball coach for
uh for a little league team or something
find a way back into that thing because
i just feel we get
lost in life a lot of people get lost
you know it's just bills right
bills and i think you you you pile it
all on yourself because
it's the it's the being afraid
of trying that thing so you do what's
safe you do was safe so for me for the
longest time i kept jabbing
like the idea of i want to do the acting
i want to do the comedy and my mom had
put into me
you can go be a lawyer and then just do
comedy on the side
so that was in the back of my mind so i
was gonna i studied political science
undergrad thinking i'm gonna be a lawyer
then my junior hotel was that in at
berkeley yeah
then uh then my junior year i went to
italy to study abroad
and there was a professor i loved what
he was doing i go maybe i'll be a
professor and i go that's a good
compromise
because that'll combine like standing in
front of a crowd and speaking but also
my parents can
you know brag you know yeah it's a
formidable job right
and when i came back my mom was freaking
out no you got to be a lawyer and i was
like what's up i thought professor
pretty good she's like no there's no
money for professors i'm like
what do you know yeah my mom was like
good point good point right
and then she's like you're going to be
wearing those jackets with the elbow
patches
jackets
it's not good it's not a good look um so
then
mom sounds awesome so then she um so
then when i and then i
then i got into a phd program for poli
sci and when i dropped out of that
was when i decided to go and pursue this
because
i had that see i had the fear always of
of trying it
because i thought well how does one even
make it in this world i have no idea so
i was good at it and i was doing plays
on the side and i was having fun but i
had a job to bring the money in because
i didn't know how you're gonna make
money
and i remember talking to this guy um i
was working in an advertising agency
that was my day job at that point
and this guy named joe ryan who is he
was in his 60s at the time
and he goes hey he saw me do a play he
goes you're pretty funny have you
thought about doing this like yeah i've
been thinking about it i'm going to wait
to raise money you know save up some
money and then go for it
and he goes listen man i'm in my 60s
right now and there were some things i
wanted to do in my 20s and i never did
it
because it was if you really have a
passion for it you should go for it and
i was 26 that was a light bulb moment
when i realized you live once you got to
live for you do what you want to do you
can't live for your parents you can't
live out of fear
so you know what you guys were saying
it's like the people that that
that don't go for their passions i think
a lot of times it's this fear that if
they go for it
like they're going to throw away
everything they have they you know the
the rent or the bills
whatever but but i think too with with
stand-up
like and for your parents or even my
parents like it's like oh i wanna do
stand-up but there's no
there's no like clear path like like if
you wanna be a professor or whatever
if you wanna make the nfl or whatever
you wanna do in that space there's
always a path if i wanna make the nfl
i play pop one and i go high school if
i'm good at that then i get scholarship
play college football then i get drafted
the nfl pretty clear
path yeah stand up yeah it's like
everyone's path is different
here i started here so there's like no
blueprint
but even that like let's go back to the
football thing right so if i'm some guy
who's
you know i mean there was a movie made
about the guy who was invisible
was that what it was the the
philadelphia eagles
uh papali yeah wasn't he like a teacher
or something he was a teacher
yeah he was a teacher and then he they
had open tryouts yeah so there you go
now he also ran a
four four forty well that's what you say
it's not listen by the way
it's not like you could be sitting there
going like oh i'm 60 years old and i've
been you know
a couch potato my whole life i'm gonna
go you know play uh quarterback for the
whatever you know the saints yeah but
the fact is
if you have a passion that is something
that like let's say you are 60 years old
and you've been working
as an accountant for the past 40 years
and it's just
just draining your soul and your passion
was football as a kid maybe you were
pretty good
what's to stop you from saying all right
you know what on the weekends i'm gonna
go help coach a team i'm just gonna
just to be out in that world yeah just
to put yourself around it
right not everyone's going to be a
comedian that wants to be a comedian but
they can work as managers they can work
in the club
they could do something so that's i
think that's part of it i think people
are afraid because they feel like
what's the their freak is the unknown
because if you if someone comes here
goes hey i wanna do stand up
all right dude go to open mics yeah you
know start there and try and build a
following
yeah big unknown yeah i think you have
to love the journey first
yeah you guys you have to love the
journey well that see that's a lot of
people don't even know
about you've got to love the journey i
think that i think that that
one of the other things that guy said to
me joe ryan it was all about like
can you can you live without this you
know you hear a lot of you hear a lot of
actors say that like i think morgan
freeman or maybe with tom hanks or
somebody was like
if you want to get into acting ask
yourself can i live without it if you
say yes
then live without it because there's
gonna be people who can't live yeah
you're not gonna make it
right yeah so similarly you know whether
it's like you know you listen to
bill gates story bill gates and steve
wozniak were
in their garage building microsoft steve
jobs
no steve jobs was apple yeah i thought
wozniak was
with steve right okay so who was with uh
paul allen was with paul
you're right you're right paul allen and
uh and bill gates were in their garage
building
um uh microsoft and so they had to stay
they were up late they were doing
whatever they had to do
and there's a drive and a passion that
you have to have for that like i'm the
kind of guy
so here's how i know i would have never
built microsoft because as soon as i
undid that computer i'd look at all
those wires i'd be like oh my god
that's a lot of work yeah you know i'll
come back but
but i had tried different career paths
out of college i tried like you know
side salesman or you know like a
professor thing and advertising and all
that stuff and it was one of those
things where
when i got faced with an obstacle
i was like i'm out i'm not going to hang
out yep come in a stand up
the first thing they teach you is get on
stage as much as you can write as much
as you can
so i'm showing up in coffee shops i'm
showing up in church basements i'm
showing up at alcoholics anonymous
meetings you name it i'm there
and this is the norcal where this was
here in socal i started oh oh you
started down here yeah
so i was showing up everywhere i could
you know you'd be telling a joke and the
guy
the barista starts making that
cappuccino so you're like
so just yeah exactly you're like why'd
the chicken cross the road
man yeah so it was it was a lot of that
and then you become a regular at the
comedy store which is the first club i
got
did you get passed by mitsubishi yeah
yeah that was that was awesome yeah man
she was amazing beautiful missy shaw was
an amazing human being i got her
so i got i i became a regular it was
either 99 or 2000. i started to stand up
in 98.
so 99 2000 she was still showing up and
she was sitting that back chair
and um did someone vouch for you yeah so
uh
so i've been coming so this this is what
i had going for me i first of all i'd
been doing play since i was 12 years old
so when i stand on stage
i'm comfortable yeah i'm good ready to
go then i took a stand-up comedy class
where they kind of helped us
write and i kind of learned how to write
a little bit then i just started hitting
the like i said every place i could hit
to perform
and along the way since i was i had a
day job at an ad agency
i had access to any kind of art
material i needed to to produce little
postcards
to pass out to people like flyers like
flyers so this is before social media
so i would get people's yeah i would get
people's uh mailing addresses and i
would mail them like monthly
postcards with me on it be like you know
here's the five shows i'm doing this
month
hit me up free tickets whatever and i
had my family i had all these people
like
i would reach out to co-workers i'd be
like i'm doing a show so i was able to
bring people these were all bringer
shows
so i show up at the bringer show which
as you guys know it's like
10 horrible comedians right with each
bringing some people
well i always succeeded in bringing like
four or
five or whatever that number was to the
show
so that helped the bookers be like oh
this guy brings people and secondly out
of the 10 people who were horrible
i was maybe two of the less horrible
yeah
so so my star like like in that circle
of bookers people were like oh book this
guy book this guy so slowly but surely
start getting booked and then and then i
i've been doing a show i think it was at
massacres cabaret this was a
a restaurant on third street and the
people booking it were like oh we have a
show in the belly room at the comedy
store you want to come do that
i was like sure now i'm showing up at
the comedy store i'm doing belly room
shows at the comedy store there was a
guy named skippy low this guy was a trip
what a great name
skippy low was like old school from like
the milton berle age
like and we couldn't tell he's very like
um
sexually ambiguous we didn't know if it
was a guy or a girl it was really hard
it's like pat
yeah he's very packed he's very pat and
his name's skip skippy so we're like is
it skippy's
so the first time i saw him he had like
white hair he had his own
cable access show where he would
interview like you know washed up stars
from the 40s
and he ran a show in the belly room
with this lady named belinda foster who
was like his
the comedian who he would help he would
have her like run run the show but he
was the boss of the show
yeah and this guy's skippy the first
time i show up again i don't know who i
don't know
what he is who he is he's wearing a
black turtleneck
and and his chest is a little like
it it's protruding can i ask titties
i swear to god i was like hi i'm here to
do the skippy logic yes darling
and he's gay right so he's like yes
darling that way and i'm like and his
voice is here so i'm like
i don't know if that's a guy or i have
no idea yeah and do i say thank you sir
thank you
i don't know what i'm going to say i'm
trying to be very polite go upstairs and
you know and i've gotten booked because
i'm able to bring people
and the funniest thing would happen so
you'd be there
and first of all skippy starts drinking
as the night goes on he's drinking red
wine
and he calls everybody mary which is
like an old-school gay thing to be like
hello mary
mary i've never heard that married mary
i'm married
everyone's married and uh and it was
funny because
he would get drunker and drunker and as
the show would go on he would tell
belinda
here's the lineup right i have i've
brought 20 people into the belly room
which
seats like 50 people exactly half the
audience is mine yeah belinda when am i
going up oh dawn
you're next you're going to be next
you'll be next and then i see skip
because
darling put him on next and i'm like oh
okay and then so she puts the next
person on
he just gets more and more drunk and
then it would get to a point where if
somebody wasn't doing well this was the
funniest [ __ ]
i swear to god this like everyone's
rookie comedians yeah
so no you know no one's killing killing
yeah i saw a few times some poor guy
would go up there and be like hi
guys how's it going and like you know 30
seconds
45 seconds one minute no laughter out of
nowhere skippy comes zooming up grab
something like
all right everybody
yeah thank you we'll see you again
sometime like just
literally that counts like [ __ ] dude the
comics like what the hell
that's the apollo saying man yeah
and so and so when that so that was my
my
uh my foot into the comedy store and i
i'll never forget one time because again
i'm a young comedian
and i got into comics i was a fan of
comedy so this is like right around 2000
and george carlin is working on
like his next special so he's at the
comedy store running in the main room
running a bunch of shows and this was
this was the comedy store's dark ages
because there was a time when the comedy
store in the early 2000s
nobody was showing up but on the
weekends if george carlin's showing up
that's gonna be a packed room
so he was on the main room going on
original room dice had just gone up
and i happened to be up in the belly
room and it was one of those like
pinch me moments where i was like holy
[ __ ] i was on stage at the same time
george carlin and andrew dice clay i go
i'm not even a regular yet but i feel
like
i'm on the right path yeah that smells
yeah and then
um i started to get to know some
comedians bobby lee some other guys
who you started with who like what was
your class my class was sam tripoli
brett ernst
sebastian maniscalco oh um uh and then
you know al madrigal came along steve
byrne you know because
al was from the northern california
comes down steve byrne from new york
comes over
uh john caparulo uh renault zizi was a
little younger than us
just i think he was a guy yeah like i
was there before like whitney came later
i'm trying to think who else was
part of that sean polovsky was there but
she was probably there a little bit
before me
and you were there when uh sebastian i
heard when sebastian first started
he was kind of the butt of the joe like
they made fun of me so bad at stand up
i'll tell you first of all before i as i
was listening to people there
rogan at the time was there and he was
one of these guys killing it but doing
his 15-minute sets
joey diaz was there brian holtzman was
there
this was like allen there back then i
think he came
he was kind of in and out he wasn't in
as much yeah but it was an interesting
time because
it was they say the the the inmates were
running the asylum yep
so what would happen is like on a
tuesday first of all
she had you know all of us going in and
out but she also had made some people
regulars
that reminded her of of other people
but they weren't that good so there was
a guy who reminded her of jim carrey
so she had him on i want to meet this
guy there was another guy who reminded
her of richard pryor had him on
so she had all these people on so like
the jim carrey guy i remember because
what would happen is
the audience would watch and you would
sense in the audience
i'm going like on a tuesday right now
you know before the pandemic on a
tuesday
original room was packed but when i was
there like in the early 2000s on a
tuesday it was like
10 10 people you're waiting to go up
you're like please just don't
leave you know and then this guy the the
the
guy who is reminds mitzi shore of jim
carrey is on stage
doing the weirdest [ __ ] you've ever
imagined and the audience is kind of
looking at each other like
is this is there a a camera like is this
part of uh
right and so you would see people just
leaving and you'd be in the background
come on just please just stay i just
want to get up on stage that's all i
want and so it was really the dark ages
at that point and a guy like sebastian
listen
he was finding his voice so sebastian
and i started right around the same time
and i i remember
geez like he and i you know it goes back
to what i was saying
sure you had the comedy store but you
still were taking whatever other gig you
could
i remember specifically there was a gig
i found um
in in newport beach and the gig was at a
nice restaurant in newport beach
and they were going to give you 15
minutes of stage time which at that
point is fantastic
and you're going to get a salmon dinner
i'm like sebastian you want to go let's
go down he's like sure
he's going to drive so we're driving on
down on the 405 south
i swear to god i don't know i don't know
exactly what happened but as we're
driving down like this
car swerves and we like fishtail a
little bit like we came this close like
spinning out
like sebastian almost didn't happen is
what i'm trying to say oh wow because of
a
salmon dinner like we would have gone
for a goddamn salmon dinner
he was working at like four seasons i
think he was like a waiter so when
sebastian was working at four seasons he
would go on his break he would
take his break he'd come up and do a set
at the store in the original
and go back now i had i had a similar
thing happen
where i at some point uh
you know want to also do acting so they
were like oh there's a play at the mark
taper forum which is a big play
there's a playwright named tony kushner
who's written a play called homebody
kabul
it's a this guy tony kushner is an
award-winning tony award-winning
uh playwright he wrote angels in america
he's amazing so i was like oh this is a
chance to
be part of something big um but the part
i had was i play a doctor who shows up
at the beginning of the play
it's a three-hour play i show up at the
beginning of the play i recite like a
two-minute monologue and then i'm gone
for two hours that's beast
but that's it i'm like oh i'm gone like
i just go i was go sit upstairs and be
like staring at the walls
and then like i started like learning
how to play the guitar and stuff and
then i was like wait a minute this is
downtown la
it's night time if i time this right i
can go do a set
and come back oh so i started doing sets
in the middle while the play was happy
because i
just have to come back for the for the
curtain call yeah so i do my
my monologue and i'll be like thank you
very much get in the car set drive do my
set
come back and they'd be like curtain
call that was it yeah you take what you
can
you know i yeah i love the kind of i
love the comment
same thing in fighting like i love when
there's like these prospects or in
stand-up like
you're these open mikers or you're just
starting to start out it's you in
sebastian driving down
you know to orange county and it's like
the the hustle to get there man
dude there's so many stories so here's
the thing so so mitchy saw me so mike
marino you know mike moreno
yeah mike mourinho uh knew me because
i'd he he'd i done
a couple of his bringer shows he was
teaching a stand-up class i took a
stand-up class
and that's where i was yeah he's a
really nice guy
funny guy funny and so he's the one i
asked i go mike you're a regular
would you recommend me and he's like i
don't know this and i go come on please
so he recommended me
and the way it works is at least back
then is you would go up you do three
minutes in front of mitzi
if she liked you she said come back next
week do six she liked you come back next
week do 10.
by the way she doesn't tell you someone
else tells you because she's not talking
she's just sitting in the back
like a mafia boss you do your three you
walk off
and you get a call going god three come
back and do six
yeah yeah from three to six to ten and
this is by by the way this is potluck
night so
you're following all the open micros
it's a weird crowd
you better hope you do well so when i
did my 10th minute
the third time i'm coming down she's
sitting in the back where the exit is
you got to walk past her she's
sitting in a little chair says exit sign
and she's eating her popcorn
and your whole time as you're walking
down you're like please just grab my arm
grab my arm because if she grabs your
arm
that means she's gonna you know anoint
you but if she doesn't grab your arm let
you walk out after the ten minutes
that means you just went through all
that [ __ ] for nothing come back in six
months or a year
right she's already seen you and she
doesn't like you get the hell out so i'm
walking past her walking past her and
all of a sudden her arm reaches out
and in my head by the way let me
backtrack a moment dude let me backtrack
for a second because
listen i got into comedy because of
eddie murphy because when i was 10 years
old nine years old eddie murphy was huge
and i had come down to la at one point
with some friends from northern
california when i was like 13 years old
and we ended up staying at a hotel
across the street from the comedy store
i didn't know what the comedy store was
but i remember driving by the comedy
store and
the friends that were showing us around
they go you know that's the biggest
comedy club in the world eddie murphy
performs there i was like holy [ __ ]
so in my mind i knew eddie murphy had
performed there so here i
am now walking past mitzi she grabs my
arm
and as she grabs my arm i'm like oh my
god this is it my career is being made
eddie murphy oh my god this is crazy
she pulls me in i lean down you know
she's older she's getting sicker but she
still
is there with us and she goes you're
very funny
i go thank you mitzi she goes i'm going
to make you a regular
i go thank you mitzi she goes have you
ever thought about wearing the outfit
i go what outfit she goes you know the
hat and the gown
i go hat and gown she goes yeah she
meant a turban
but she did this to a lot of guys this
is what people don't realize she did to
a lot of people
bro don't i i i'm sorry guys like wear
costumes and [ __ ] all the time
all these thoughts are going through my
head because i'm like
what do i say oh what and i go i go kind
of offended yeah
and i go i go yeah yeah that's a great
idea yeah sure
yeah and i will turn i walk down the
stairs because she goes yeah i'm gonna
make you a regular
call call monday for a veil i walk down
the stairs i go in the hallway like what
the hell did i just agree to you gotta
find the turbine i'm gonna wear turban
and a friggin
dustasha
yeah hell yeah yeah that should be cool
yeah
so i so that i i thought in the back of
my head i go you know she's older maybe
she forgets
and and dude on monday corey who was the
booker
they call her queen corey she was uh
she's freddy soto's
widow she at the time she calls me up
she knew me she goes
hey moss congratulations i heard you're
a regular i go yeah corey i
am she goes and mitzi said you're gonna
be wearing the outfit i was like
so you have to go get the outfit bro no
so then it was like two weeks of trying
to figure out
how to get out of the outfit so you know
i was talking to my sister about it i'm
trying to get advice from people
and then i told co i told corey what you
just said i go corey i don't know about
wearing it out like a turban on stage
and she goes maz let me just tell you
something she goes mitzi is a genius
if she sees something for you you got to
go with it she goes she helped
roseanne shop for her clothes to create
the roseanne character
she helped andrew dice clay become
andrew dice clay she is a genius
now granted what you just said you know
if you talk to mark maron he'll tell you
when he became a regular
she told him to wear a scarf because
you're the poet yes you wanted to always
wear something right
mark's like what and then there's
another guy his name was joey bananas i
think
banana suit right jackie banana whatever
this guy i guess had an
act where he would do 15 minutes and he
wore like the banana suit at the last
minute
mitzi saw it one time she goes you're
jackie bananas you got to wear the
banana suit the whole time
yeah yeah we've never seen him since
yeah ruined his career
so it wasn't it wasn't like listen i
love mitzi i've never met but the
stories that love her support yeah
some misses like it wasn't 100 percent
like no you know jerry seinfeld came and
she didn't pass jerry seinfeld yeah yeah
that story yeah it wasn't 100 and so it
wasn't 100
a little i mean i mean you know i'm i'm
guessing the guy might have done a fruit
of lume
uh commercial or something critical
suicide yeah so i don't know what
happened
so so i was like okay how do i get out
of this so then i started negotiating
because now corey by the way who was the
who was the
you know the booker she loved
movies from the 30s and i don't know if
you guys know who rudolf valentino is
but he's he was this
actor from the silent movie era and uh
and he was
um he was the there he is rudolph
valentino
and he had a character called the sh the
shake right there
i think that's what it is really if i
did turn her classy was the turban on
yeah with the turban on
he was like this you know leading man i
think
i think the character was called the
shake it looks intense yeah he wasn't he
was like he was like you know
he was a heartthrob at the time right
and and
the character was like white guy doing
brown face exactly yeah look at the lips
so the character there the son of the
[ __ ] yeah he was the shake so the
character was this like
leading man hero right so i'm just
talking
i'm talking to corey and i'm like corey
you know what rather than wearing like a
turban maybe i can be like
a leading like maybe that's a character
i do in the middle of my act i've become
the leading man to shake and she's like
you know i love that idea i'm going to
tell mitzi
you're going to be the shake and i was
like ha i walked out i'm like i just
negotiated something i don't want to do
it so then i'm like okay i got to get
out of this [ __ ] how do i get out of
this [ __ ]
and then i remembered now i was but
you're still stoked you got past
i'm happy i'm past yeah but i ain't
gonna wear no [ __ ] tournaments
you gotta say what i'm saying it's a
tough
it's a tough time i don't care who you
are yeah it's not
i'm not no i'm never because the other
the other compromise i thought of was
eddie murphy used to do a great
character on saturday night live called
mr robinson's neighborhood yeah
great which was his take on mr rogers
neighborhood
and this is now before september 11th
but still you know
muslim terrorist is still a thing so i
had an idea for like a sketch
or like a portion of a show where i
would do mr raheem's neighborhood
yeah so i had that idea too so i was
like maybe in the middle of my act
i'll turn into a character you know so
i'm trying to find the right way and
and the way i got out of this was so
again i was born in iran
uh left when i was six grew up in
america now the islamic republic of iran
is a very oppressive government
and there's a lot of people in the west
who are iranians who hate that
government you know
no i don't like the government they're
very oppressive to their people yeah
that's why they left so
but there's all these persian tv
channels
out of america where these people like
will get on tv and they'll
cuss out the leaders in iran and just do
all kinds of stuff
well there was one guy who used to dress
up as a mullah who's like the clerics
like the turban and all that
from iran and he used to dress up and
make fun of them in videos
this dude one time was at the federal
building or somewhere there was a rally
against the government
of iran and he's making fun of the
you know the mullahs the clerics and
some supporter of the clerics showed up
definitely killed him
no didn't kill him but they threw some
rocks at the guy hit him in the eye
blinded him
oh wow when i heard that story i was
like
that's my out i mean i don't want to do
this look at this guy
i called up corey now at the time my
father had moved back to iran so he was
in iran so i came up with multiple
layers
for work so my father was a successful
businessman moves to america
buys a lot of property ends up losing
all of his money in the properties he
bought
goes back to iran to try and get his you
know properties going again and
basically spends
the rest of his life in iran before he
passes away in america in 2009 but
um he was in iran at the time
and so the other problem is so i was i
was layering all my reasons why i'm not
going to wear the turbans
so i said first of all i said listen
corey i said you know my father's in
iran
if i'm wearing the turban somebody finds
out i'm wearing a turban they get upset
at me they go after him
number one number two i said these guys
showed up and they threw a rock at that
guy they blinded him
so i said they could come after me they
could come after the club
now you can't do that anymore at all
like that kind of gimmick stuff like
there's no way no no you couldn't do it
then
i can't imagine there was a time where
you could get away with like dude
like a banana guy pretty much everyone
who did that like went away because the
whole point of comedy is your voice got
to become your pure suicide you know
so back then if i showed up with
sebastian and sam tripoli and brett
ernest it was like hey guys
uh i got a turban on they have you lit
listen as soon as i walked away i know
they'd be like what the [ __ ] is he doing
so i actually um it was funny so as soon
as i tell corey that she's like
oh my gosh i didn't know about that she
let me call you back so obviously she
calls mitzi
two minutes later she calls up sick just
wear something comfortable yeah
we're in baby there you go well you know
you
now but his real name was ned yeah and
she was like no no
you're carlos mencia you gotta lean into
the mexican thing
yeah and even though he's named he's
honduras honduras he's not
mexican oh wait he's honduras yeah he's
honduran and i think his
mother is like uh um uh or one of his
parents is
from from so they're honduran and um
hungarian or something like that like
it's a mix
but again but that was that was mitzi
yeah saying hey you really yeah your
name's carlos mencia change your name
ned's not gonna work change your name
yeah and also lean into the mexicans
listen she's again
i think her thing was like trying to
market you into something that she
thought
would like sell tickets right yeah but
but the fact is
again hit and miss right so i was able
to talk my way out of that but then she
comes back around
and she does she does a great thing in
putting us together for a tour that
ended up becoming the axis of evil
and what happened was so in 2000 mitzi
was very political like she would watch
a lot of news
and um there was an uprising with the
palestinians and the israelis
they called it intifada so there was
conflict in that part of the world again
intifada yeah so palestinians in israel
she's watching us cnn this 2000 before
september 11th
and she says she has a lightbulb moment
she's like there's going to be a need
for a positive voice for muslim people
in the near future this is before
september 11th
so at the time i was the only comedian
of a middle eastern background
at the club and mitzi had always had
like ladies night
black night latino night so she decides
to do
a middle eastern night she calls it the
arabian nights so we all start getting
calls like do you know any other middle
eastern comedians
she had seen ahmed ahmed so she tells
him come be a part of this
i had seen aaron cater one time he's
half palestinian half mormon i go
i know this guy he comes on sam tripoli
here's here's now here's convenient well
yeah so here's where it this is where my
mind starts going
to help my buddies up tripoli had
auditioned for mitzi because tripoli was
like his material might have been a
little
more it wasn't leaning into his
ethnicity at all
and it might have been a little edgier
so when he auditioned for mitsy hit you
know doing the three to six to ten
whatever it was
she didn't pass them and they were like
just you know go away come back later
well at this time duncan trussell had
become the booker of the club and
duncan's friends with
yeah duncan's friends with sam he's
friends with me everything duncan's the
one calling me up do you know any other
middle easterners and i go
duncan you know sam's last name is
tripoli tripoli is the capital of
libya i wonder if there's any middle
eastern him so i call up sam he's my
buddy go dude
are you middle eastern he goes with my
mom or somebody's armenian i'm half
armenian
i think that's good enough bro
you're in i follow up
all that time of like no no no she's
like
and the show the arabian nights
originally started out because i i
remember talking about
i'm like dude black comedy night there's
you know
a thousand black comedians and a big
black population that'll come see it
women night they'll come see it latina
and i they go i go middle eastern who
the [ __ ] coming to see middle eastern
tonight
well we listen to mitzi on that and
she was right on that because what it
was was there was a need for
that voice yeah and also she originally
just had it like she was like anybody
who's brown that's not mexican or black
you're on the show
so we had this like indian dude that was
like
british indian she had a girl who was
white but she did like a belly dance
move in the middle of her show
it was very secure yeah exactly that's
where she got her start
no but it was it was this mishmash of a
show and then eventually
me ahmed and aaron and sam
became the original arabian knights
and then from there we were like well
iranians aren't arabs iranian ethnically
speaking it's like saying to like
uh you know a puerto rican you're
mexican it's like no i'm not i'm puerto
rican
so similarly with the iranian thing um
we were like we need another name that's
a little edgier and that's when george
bush had come out and said there's an
access of evil it's north korea iran and
iraq
so we're like what about the access of
evil comedy tour and that's when me
ahmed and aaron took ownership of it
because sam again was not necessarily
middle eastern like that so
born and raised
but he got into the club for that yeah
we did that a couple times
there was another show because mitzi by
the way when she
when she's into you she's into you so
she would like come to the club and
there was times when
i'd be like you know down the list over
here and then some
the booker would whatever the guy
running it would come over be like
you're next
i mean what mitzi wants to wants you to
go oh wow oh [ __ ] i better deliver yeah
you know and you
thank god you go up and you do well
great so we were doing a big show in the
main room one time
missy shows up and you know the lineup
is
in a specific order and that's when bret
ernst was one of my friends as well that
started out with me he's hilarious and
i'm like you know
and brett had like tried to be a regular
and wasn't hadn't been getting any love
and so he was supposed to go up and
whoever it is comes over and goes
mitzi wants you to go next and i was
like oh my god i was hoping she'd watch
brett and then me
and like doesn't matter mitchy wants you
next i go do me a favor just tell her
you couldn't find me
and we tricked we tricked it brett goes
up kills it
regularly oh like where are you putting
people on my mind
yeah like well now
you know you have adam yeah you know he
runs it and passes people yeah but
they're still not that like
mitzi you know like dude don't get me
wrong i respect the [ __ ] i've adam and
you want you want to do well in front of
adam yeah but there's not like a mitzi
bitsy was like i i will wear wear it as
a badge of honor that i got to
experience her and and i tell everybody
you know people say like you know what
are some of your career highlights
definitely becoming a regular at that
club
that club i grew exponentially at that
club yes because one of the things
comedians don't know like i find like
young comedians sometimes or
people are very new to the game they'll
be like can i come open for you and i'm
like
dude you come open for me in front of a
thousand hot fans who have
spent money and they're gonna laugh at
anything yeah and
do your seven minutes but you should
find places to get up
where it's like late nobody knows who
you are and there's three people 100
percent
that's the kind of [ __ ] we had to do
early on and the thing was she would put
you up like
i remember being up i was a clean
comedian i didn't cuss that much
and i was doing some political material
but she was still giving me the midnight
spot
on a tuesday i remember talking to joey
diaz about i was like why am i
up here following joe diaz brian
holtzman whatever it was
what it's impossible to do and he's like
bro she's got a plan for you bro
she's put you up early you got to just
go into it
i did i learned to i learned to adapt to
follow the joe rogans and to follow like
one of the
more of the one of the times i remember
and this is another lesson i learned
with stand-up
one of the times i remember kind of
dying of death was following joey diaz
because you guys know joey diaz is so in
the moment and so all over the place i
love one of the things he said
i remember watching him one night and he
was just killing but he was all over the
place and he comes off i go
joey d i go you got i go do you ever put
a setlist together
he goes you know how it is bro you got
your setlist all set and ready to go you
get up on that stage
you gotta start calling audibles
that's hard because yeah yeah football
right yeah
um but i remember one night and this is
the lesson i learned he killed
and i went on stage and i got into my
act
and nobody was paying attention because
he had just thrown a bomb in the room
and people were still talking and stuff
and that's when i realized if somebody
kills or dies in front of you
you got to go up and acknowledge that so
ever since after that i learned
forget my act forget what i you got to
run a set
for for a late night show move get that
out of the way yeah you got to go up and
acknowledge what just happened
and ever since then i learned like you
know following dice one night because
these that back then dice would show up
eddie griffin would show up paul mooney
would show up they would do one two
hours sometimes three bumping one time
bump everybody so you're sitting there
it's like you know you're supposed to be
i told my then girlfriend now wife like
hey i'll be back
i've got a set at midnight i'll be back
by 12 30.
uh-uh this guy's coming that you're
calling her like eddie griffin's got a
lot on his mind tonight
sorry dave yeah and then so
so i just remember dice was up there and
he's up there and again
granted this is the middle of the iraq
war with america i'm very anti-war
i want to get up there and be like you
know i can't believe george bush did
this and this but i got jokes i got
punchlines
dice is up there he's doing some bit and
he's like you know you ever get in there
and did it
and you're with the girl and now you're
doing suck ass suck ass
suck ass and then he goes and dies to
this day he'll talk about it and he says
i've heard him talk about this on
interviews because he says there's no
meaning he's
he just starts going hot soup
[Music]
and i'm like what is this but the 10
people in the crowd are dying
to die he's killing and i'm like and
they know dice he's a legend right
and then he's all right who's next he's
like you know and
at that point probably didn't even know
who i was like oh this guy okay maz
by the way i've become friends with him
since and he and he would call me the
foreign comic
he's a foreign guy yeah he's like who's
next
this guy's got i don't know i must be
fine he's over here i don't know
the worst intro ever yeah ever by the
way the worst intro ever was i'm not
kidding one time he was doing in the
middle of all that suck at seconds
the mike gave feedback okay again
granted 10 people in the room
dying of his show mike gives feedback it
goes
some weird thing he looks at the mic
drops the mic
looks at the audience walks off stage
and everyone's like what the hell just
happened i'm next
oh so i gotta run up on stage be like
okay people people think i'm like the
mic guy or something
hey but what i learned was following
like having died of death after joey
diaz i was like i can't go up on stage
and just be like after suck ass you'd be
like what's up with george bush and the
yeah i went up there i was like i just
go suck ass suck
i start repeating what i said yeah and i
go i don't know about you guys i go
that's stuck in my head all night i'm
gonna be [ __ ] i'm gonna be peeing in
the middle of the night i'm gonna be a
suck ass what the hell is that
and i just went on and on about his show
for like a minute or two
so people knew i'm in the room and then
i like transitioned into my thing
those are the kinds of things you learn
at that place to follow people
in that kind of situation i followed
martin lawrence one time he showed up
he packed the place this is when the
place was dead and this is when it's
martin lawrence martin lawrence shows up
at a morning station here in la this is
when i'm used to
showing up on a tuesday or wednesday to
10 people
i pull up there's a line outside the
comedy store door like
a line the club is full and i go what
the hell is going on they go martin
lawrence announced he's doing a set
tonight
packed he does 30 minutes and to his
credit back in the day he used to do
longer sets
but at this point he was like i'm
sticking to my 30. he does this 30
and he's like all right who's next and
they're like maz he's like all right
again he didn't know me
i think this guy's funny he's here did
you even know you were going to follow
martin i know it's fine
but i'm sitting there back watching and
when he goes i got when he says i got to
go
everyone in the crowd's like no come on
yeah but you don't even know man i
because i'd learned my lesson yeah first
thing i do when i go up there everyone
you know give it up for moz and then
everyone's like oh you go boy i go up
and i go i go hey man
i go i'm just as upset as you guys are
yeah hello you think i wanted to follow
my lawyers
i'm in the back going keep going i don't
need to do my spot so i made fun of my
own situation i know you follow martin
luther's [ __ ] yeah
you think this is easy and now they're
buying into mine like
oh okay he knows what's going on yeah
like you're
aware of what the [ __ ] just happened i
know what the [ __ ] just happened
another time i got so many of these
stories another time this was one of the
craziest times all right so eddie murphy
eddie murphy was showing up at uh
tripping on tuesdays
to watch all like like earthquake was
killing and all these guys
eddie murphy show up in the main room
with charlie murphy and a team and they
would just sit there
in the main booth watch watch the main
room packed on a tuesday it's packed
the main room original room still empty
right you know
20 30 people paulie shore who knows
eddie from back in the day
uh goes goes up to eddie in the main
room
and convinces eddie to come watch
paulie's set
he's like hey i'm going to be doing my
set in the original room can you come
watch so i see eddie murphy
i'm watching all this right and i'm
following paulie i'm next but i'm but
this is my comedy hero
is walking past me and he goes and he
sits there he's watching
paulie and he's sitting in the mitzi
shore seat which is right by the exit
watching paulie i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm
like oh my god and how's paulie doing
paul's doing fine but i'm sitting there
going like oh my god if paulie finishes
and eddie stays he might see me this is
pretty oh my
god this is i'm like oh world please
just a line this is amazing
so as paulie's finishing up
i see eddie get up and just sneak out
because eddie's smart
he knows what's coming because two
minutes later paulie sure goes
ladies and gentlemen we've got one of
the biggest
comedians in the history of comedy he
has not done comedy
in 30 years he's coming up tonight to do
it for you
give it up ladies and gentlemen eddie
murphy
original people camp people are running
down the hallway
people oh my god and then eddie's not
there right
he's like eddie come on up eddie and
then you got i think it was
josh who comes over he's like uh eddie
went back to the main room
he goes well go get him we're all
waiting
paulie's killing time paulie's like
eddie murphy is coming back tonight he
used to come here
i'm in the background like i just hope
eddie just shows up so i can watch and
he'll just do something i don't want to
[ __ ] go off anymore
bro josh walks back in he goes i i told
him
uh he goes what'd you tell him he goes i
told him polly short said come to the
original room
and he goes what did he say he said [ __ ]
off
so i'm like and then he probably goes
all right well then all right who's next
then
and they go maz he's like he's like well
he's kind of like the persian eddie
murphy
or you had some tough followers all
right bro i went up on stage and i just
i took the mic i go listen man
i'm more disappointed than everyone i go
i feel like we were at the club tonight
and we were talking to the hottest girl
all night
and then the lights came up and she was
gone
and the and the most unattractive girl
is left and i'm that girl yeah
i go you guys just got the last of the
night you know
and again they were with me because they
felt what i was talking about
you know those moments are beautiful
yeah yeah you want those moments
bro and i've had listen by the way the
other thing i wanted to say was eddie
murphy
having wanted to be at that club now
because when when i
you know they put your name they spelt
you write your name on the on the on the
black wall
so um when i became a regular for
whatever reason they were like we're not
putting up names right now because it
costs too much
like the cub the club wasn't doing well
and once i think it was kirk fox
somebody became a regular and they were
like
i'll pay the painter to put up the names
so they put my name up and the beauty of
it is
my name now at the comedy store is in
front by the main room
and it's on it's just a little bit above
eddie murphy's man
what a story and i'm like holy [ __ ] i
wanted to be here and here i am
but i'll tell you one last story about
eddie murphy one night
same around the same time he's coming in
the back and watching blah blah blah
i had just gotten back from a tour in
australia
where i was doing an hour hour plus i'm
headlining right
and i don't know if you guys have ever
felt it but when you come off the road
where you're doing an hour hour hour and
then you got to go do 15. it's tough
you don't know like you don't it's like
starting to stop and you're like oh my
god what do i even have 15. it's all
over the place
so it was one of those things where
we're on autopilot you land at home and
you call the club on a monday you're
like i'm available every night
even though i should have just been like
give me a week off but i was like i'm
available i'm ready to go so they call
me they're like tuesday night you're on
all right so i go up there and i'm like
start stop start stop having a mediocre
set
and i'm bringing up steve byrne after me
and steve always does it like he always
mess around with me when he bring me up
like you know jeff scott who now has
passed away the piano guy
uh when you ask you would ask him who's
next and jeff would always be like
monsieur brownie and then steve would
always be like who
he'd be like maz gibran he's like i
never heard of this guy
sounds ethnic not sure if i trust him
so i would mess back with steve right
i'd be like steve what and you know
so i have what i consider a mediocre set
but i'm as i'm having this set in the
back of my mind
a voice comes in and goes dude wake up
and deliver
but then the other voice comes in and
goes no man the whole point of this
original room
is that you can do whatever you want i
go who who could be in the audience that
would make a difference it doesn't
matter like
because the club had always been like
workout workout yeah don't worry about
the industry
so i was like i can't be disappointed
this is fine like just
hang in there and keep this keep trying
your mediocre jokes and see if any of
them sticks
i like show danger yeah who could be
here tonight well
after i introduce steve with another
like weird
introduction i come off stage and
there's a guy named johnny zapp
who was like the uh bar fly
of the comedy store he used to hang out
and he would tell you things like oh
yeah man i used to help richard pryor
write his jokes and like really
really but he's sitting in the audience
and as i'm walking past him because the
room is really dark he grabs my arm he's
like
hey man eddie's here and i was like oh
that's great because i thought eddie's
in the main room
and and he goes yeah eddie and then i
was like okay and as i'm walking
out of the original room unbeknownst to
me eddie murphy has come into the
original room and
sat in mitzi's chair and seen my
mediocre set oh no
and i walked past eddie murphy i'm like
oh [ __ ] and then i go downstairs and i'm
in the hallway there
and i'm like i hope he didn't see the
whole thing
and i see him get up from the chair go
down the stairs
come into the hallway i'm trying to make
eye contact
he avoids eye contact oh
god and it was so bad and then in the
back of my mind i thought because this
is the thing
i always say i got into comedy because
you're inspired in life by greatness and
mediocrity
and i got into comedy because i saw a
couple guys who were mediocre
and i was like if they can do it i can
do it yeah so in the back of my mind i'm
thinking all right
i hope eddie murphy saw me tonight and i
was so bad
that he'll end up on a talk show and
when they asked him what made you come
back he'd be like there was this one
persian comment
he was so bad i thought you know i can
come back
wow hell yeah that was so inspiring yeah
yeah
thank you yeah i want to build something
that's yeah i know right man i'm gonna
go home
but it's all about the journey that's
basically what you're saying about the
journey
yeah well you boys are on the road
friday and saturday so yeah yeah
where you guys headed uh san marcos
texas okay
okay tech's really the only place you
know texas arizona
nashville florida especially florida i
did arizona
just to see just to be able to say that
i've done stand-up indoors under the
pandemic and i'll be honest with you
guys
i felt a little uncomfortable simply
because
i saw in the room half the crowd masked
half the crowd not mass i could tell
some people were nervous some people
weren't and i was like you know what i'm
just going to lay low
till we get to a point where everyone
can just not have that
thought in their minds and for indoor
shows you know yeah i
yeah and i get that i think for certain
comics especially their crowd i don't
know what your crowd is
um mine's like 18 to 36 males
right in shape they don't when i say
this yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
you know i'm like can you guys catch
kind of
maybe a mask wouldn't know the bat like
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah
well that's been great but listen we
love stand up like that's why
like when even doing the set i did at
the uh outdoor show
that's what i live for you know you you
feel alive after i want to do that again
i think you realize that in the pandemic
to your point it's like
something you can't live without or
something you can't do without i
you know it's to me i'll talk to comic
and they're like yeah dude i'm just not
worried about i'll shut it down
2022 i'm like oh i can't do that i don't
want to do that yeah
i'll do it wherever well i've been doing
a lot of like zoom shows which at first
i was hesitant to do but then i realized
they actually work because you just get
like 10 of the people you unmute them
so you can hear the laughter and you can
do crowd work because you're seeing
people and it's not just their clothes
now it's their homes
make fun of them like that yeah so i've
done those i've done some uh outdoor
social distancing shows that have been
great because people are desperate to
get out
yes yes that's the other thing big time
so all that stuff i've been doing
and uh and we keep going man doing my
podcast doing
you know doing this kind of stuff you're
on all things uh accounting network all
these comments called back to school
with maz giobrani i just bring
people uh the idea was my kids would ask
me questions i didn't know the answers
for
that's some [ __ ] some crazy [ __ ] you
gotta be like neil degrasse tyson yeah
sometimes i'll google it but sometimes
like who cares
exactly so so instead of googling i said
it's crazy
[ __ ] like you know stuff that you should
know as a dad
why does it rain i don't [ __ ] know
because this my son asked me when i say
dad how long does it take to get to mars
because there's a uh that matt damon
who's on tv yeah and he's like oh we're
where's he i'm like he's on mars and
he's like can we live there i'm like
they're trying to figure it out like
elon musk there and he goes how long
will it take a skit to mars like you've
never
yeah what yeah and i was like i don't
know i mean would that's exactly 500
days
that's exactly it you get vague answers
oh but
you don't want vague answers yeah
because you want him going to school
yeah
and then then my dad's an idiot well but
him yeah my dad's a dumbass
or my dad says we can get during three
months and the teacher's like that's
full of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
google you know it takes like 500 some
days dude exactly
so that's why like for the show i bring
on like experts and and we learned from
them
so i actually had a guy who helped land
the rover on mars oh i love it yeah so
he came and talked and i had um i had
also um
i had on uh um tehran's my co-host i had
um
uh i love him yeah tehran's great i had
michael cohen who was trump's fixer
yes he was on oh really yeah i had a
lady who was a cave diver she dives
underneath glaciers to look for
organisms
so it's crazy and it's become an excuse
to just talk so it's a fun show it's
dope
yeah and it always starts with a
question from my kids that's my son
right there in his pajamas oh i love it
yeah
oh yeah the dragon yeah so they'll ask
they'll ask a question at the top
and uh and uh and then we go from there
so it's been yeah they're good
it's been fun to do if you need some
questions let me know my son will
ask some insane bro we should have you
on to talk about fighting
that'll be good whatever you want man
yeah yeah we'll have you on and do it
yeah yeah yeah that's fine because it's
just talking it's just it's an excuse to
talk
yes right and then you also find out how
many interesting things people are doing
yeah you know
something um so yeah it's been that's
been do i've been doing that and then
the special i got that special coming
out
the sword comes that drops tomorrow is
that right drops tomorrow it's
on uh on uh peacock which is the new uh
nbc
streamer and it's called pandemic
warrior the story with the special was
december 2019 i went to dubai i filmed
the special and it was called peaceful
warrior
and i was like all right i'll go back
home i'll sell this
and i will uh you know uh um
i got all my tour dates my career is
going to take off in 2020 this is my
year
and then as we were talking everything's
just stopped and so
what happened was great cover yeah i'm
not to say yeah i was watching
a lot of specials that came out when
the pandemic hit and they'd been shot
before the pandemic and you can tell and
you could tell it's weird because i was
like it looks like they shot this on
mars because like there's an audience
together
no one's masked and the comedian is
talking about traffic like what's going
of the references you're just like oh
exactly so i decided what i'm going to
do is if i'm going to do this right i go
what i'll do is i'll do like
five minutes at the top from inside my
closet where i've been doing comedy
and then i'll be like now let's go watch
the specialized shot and then at the end
i'll do another few minutes
from the closet so it's irrelevant yeah
related to it so peaceful warrior became
pandemic warrior love it
and again how does it stand up in uh
dubai
it's fantastic dude is it good dude
people love dubai man dude
just not just dubai but the whole middle
east there's a lot of
when we went in 2007 with the access to
the evil comedy tour
it was the first time there was a group
of american comics who came to the
middle east to perform for the people of
the middle east
but ever since 2007 to now it has just
like taken off and comedy's a big thing
there and if you think about it like you
got youtube you got netflix
they know us yes worldwide you know so
when you go to do shows
in dubai or in beirut or in jordan or
wherever you're going
fans show up they love it and because
they're not as spoiled as we are in the
west where you could watch
the pre-pandemic you'd watch stand-ups
seven nights a week yeah they come out
they come out and it's fantastic yeah
yeah i highly recommend i tell people
when this pandemic ends travel like i've
done i've done the middle east
i did australia i've done europe i did
indonesia
did you do ireland um i didn't i did
ireland i did dublin on
me too unreal yeah unreal it's amazing
same thing they're so
grateful that you came out there in
australia too yeah that american comic
will come out there the crowds are
nuts yeah yeah yeah that's awesome i
experienced that nuts
so that's it yeah i'll check out your
special man i appreciate that
yeah yeah academic warrior never worry i
hope it makes sense still like you said
it's like
some of the stuff we were talking about
before yeah it's weird to watch comics
that have released them during the
pandemic and it's just yeah just i i
think the the best special i saw that
hit the hardest and it's because he did
it he shot it during the pandemic with
kevin hart's
from his house yeah you're like i can
relate to that especially if kids are
like dude he's crushing it
absolutely and that's what in all
honesty like i wanted to do a
pandemic only special where was an hour
of just pandemic material
but the logistics of putting it together
were too hard and i had this hour
already shot so
that's why i kind of compromised and
said i'll do the few minutes at the top
then i'm hoping some of the jokes that
are on there still irrelevant still work
but at least i'm trying to put you in
the frame
of mind of saying i know what i know yes
yep you know because even when you watch
like a movie or a tv show that was shot
pre-pandemic
someone's shaking hands and hugging i'm
like what the hell is going on there
yeah
the different feelings yeah well we love
you man thank you for finally coming on
brother
thanks for having me you guys check out
his special show all the best
yeah that was so fun man yeah man let
your wife see us touching yeah i know
i washed my hands i washed my hands i
went around
touched my face i didn't touch my face
appreciate you
thanks guys what's up y'all they call me
chappelle
i can't get in the clubs no more because
my shoes is too tight lacey
that's online that's what they call you
is from my dad shout out to him he did
17 years to the joint hard time
okay hard time get you some hardcore
tests you know what i'm saying
i can't get into clubs no more
look at the back right there i brushed
it yeah filling it nicely
look at this come on look what they say
read that chain
play a [ __ ] on it yeah you know what i'm
saying
exactly no these guys with the pink
laces you know me
like the socks sucks tactics who was
that on the side it's kind of wrinkled
so i can't see we've pulled up a little
bit
there oh [ __ ] smell like b-boys that's a
little rolly
yeah little rolly boy rolly on the side
on the bottom
yeah you can get oh there it is all
right cool yeah i mean the 43 shout out
to the real 43 for these socks man
yeah 43. oh yeah he threw his dope shot
yeah he's got a prayer that has review
on your socks
yeah a picture yeah here he got all of
us on our on there
really yeah well where out where's our
everybody's shoes made in china these
are chinese
everything we wear is made in china
these are the chinese
jordan thighs all right custom-made
all right i use an x-acto knife to
custom make them myself
you see the prints there's those wuhan
jays
[Laughter]
they living it up their bat soup
specials
those yelling